e
e e
stops everyone please find a seate
I open the hearing of the children and
family law committee on Tuesday January
28th 2025 first up is House Bill
322 allowing a parent paying child
support to retain the exclusive right to
claim the child as a dependent on it
should be his or her tax return and the
speaker calls up representative Barton
who is the Prime sponsor
not yet there we go thank you Mr
chairman
welcome you may begin thank you um so I
I submitted this piece of legislation um
some of you may or may not know that in
2018 since
2018 uh child support payments are no
longer um tax deductible so you can't
claim child support on your as as a tax
exemption you still have to pay taxes on
all the child support you would pay to
the other spouse from one spouse to
another um and it doesn't count as
income for the person receiving so they
it's Tech technically it's support for
the child but um it's uh it doesn't
count as as income and
uh it it seems an unjustice since 2018
since the payer can't take the exemption
they ought to at least take the child
tax credit as they're the primary
Financial um uh supporter uh of the
child uh so they should have uh the
exclusive right to claim the child if
they are providing financial support
exclusively
uh that's all I had to say on this on
this um this bill I'm happy to take any
questions or provide any
rebuttal questions representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here representative and for taking
my question so my question is we do know
within child support that sometimes
people are paying child support and it
might even be like $50 a month so they
are not the prime like um supporter
Financial supporter of the child so in
that case why would they be able to um
claim them on their taxes if the other
person is providing more I'm I'm I'm not
sure how you could say that they're not
the the the prime supporter even if they
were paying $1 that would be $1 from one
spouse to the other why isn't the other
spouse paying anything they're they're
the primary supporter because they are
they're paying to the other spouse
either they have they're making more
money the court determined that that
they make more more money I think what
would happen as a result of the passage
of this legislation is if there was uh
if it was determined that there the
disparity or that the $2,000 tax credit
would um essentially be a wash or that
it would be a benefit to one party to
the other they should just not have
child support and and uh there would be
no child support payment and they could
alternate tax years for um for the
exemption which would be much more
valuable to either spouse so the $50
argument I think is pretty pretty moot
representative Greg for the followup um
I appreciate your opinion on that it's
my question is though how how much does
it take to provide for a child like if
somebody's supplying $50 a month how
much do you think it actually takes to
provide for the child and where the rest
of that money coming from uh thank you
for that question so in the state of New
Hampshire I guess um some children are
more valuable than others uh based on on
child child support payment it's all
about the the income of the parents of
the child that's how it's how it's
decided so if the parents are providing
equal financial support to the child it
would be it would be essentially a wash
but if you reach if essentially if one
one parent is paying
$166 67 cents per month that would
equate to $2,000 a year so maybe that's
the threshold that would the parties get
together and say it's a wash we might as
well just alternate the tax credit
instead of um one person having to pay
taxes on top of that $166 a month
whatever that minimum is because they're
punished by having to pay the taxes on
top of it it's free money for the person
that's receiving it so why wouldn't they
uh get the tax
exemption representative Raymond thank
you I want to follow up on what you just
said about um paying taxes on it because
I'm confused how one pays taxes on child
support uh yeah I'm happy to explain
that so how you pay taxes is in order to
pay money to the other party you have to
first earn it and when you earn that
money you pay income taxes to the
federal government on that money that
you earn so you pay the taxes first and
then you give the taxfree money to the
recipient that's how do you know what
the New Hampshire followup
representative thank you Mr chairman I
apologize that's okay um do you know
what the New Hampshire fiscal policy uh
Institute has estimated the annual costs
are for things like child care or rent
in New
Hampshire uh I don't and I think it's I
think it's completely irrelevant to this
to this case it's all about uh if if one
parent is paying money to another they
have to pay taxes on it they should they
can't get a tax exemption anymore so
they ought to be able to claim
the child as a dependent uh on their on
their tax form like they could before
2018 representative any for further just
just one one last one would it surprise
you to know that the average cost of
child care is almost $20,000 a year in
New Hampshire and the average cost of a
two-bedroom apartment is $1900 a
month I uh no it wouldn't thank you
representative Corson
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here to answer our questions um in
regards to the if if one party pays the
other spouse a dollar um doesn't the
custodial parent pay for that child and
everything that that the other spouse is
not paying for I mean if you have a a
husband who's paying a dollar in child
support wouldn't the parent that is
taking care of the rent and the bills
and everything else be paying a lot more
than that
dollar I I think that would be
determined um by the court I mean the
court would determine um you know who
has to pay what but I if they're not
each each parent and and I I believe
we're a 5050 state or at least we
promote that um but each parent would uh
provide essentially equal care for that
child they have a they have an equal
burden and um whether it's the father or
the mother who's the primary fin
Financial uh provider they still have to
pay taxes to whatever and whatever
they're they're owed or whatever is
ordered and um whether whether they have
primary custody or second or or you know
a lower Arrangement it shouldn't matter
because they're the P primary Financial
uh and it's $2,000 that we're talking
about it's not
$20,000 it's not $30,000 the burden that
burden is shared it's it's the taxes
that are paid on the child support that
that since 2018 there's an imbalance on
and so you know if if the if the amount
was
$166 a month it would be a wash I can
tell you it's probably 10 times that for
for a lot of cases so $2,000 is very
small than a tax exempt you would have
received before 2018 so a lot of the
arguments here are move follow up um
thank you the the custodial parent is
going to be putting in the rest of that
amount to raise that child the
regardless of the Court the Court's
decision of whether somebody has to pay
$50 the custodial parent then is paying
a lot more so to automatically
give the first spouse the tax exemption
just seems
wrong I is that is there a question make
sure it's a question sorry sorry um that
was a question okay next time would you
believe
sorry um so to comment on that um if
you're saying one one uh one parent pays
more than the other they should be they
should be providing equal support from
the family from the um family courts I
don't know how you can say one parent is
paying more than than the other just you
know sporadically like like that um in
in many cases um there is an inequality
and but but the court should say you
have this burden and you have this
burden and it ought to be balanced
fairly whether it's the time with the
child um the the amount of care that's
given from from one custodial parent to
the other um but at the end of the day
when it comes to finances it used to be
the person paying the child support
could declare it as an exemption and
probably thousands and thousands of
dollars declare it as an exemption and
they would alternate years or they would
come up to some arrangement with
declaring the um the child as a tax
credit which is is really small dollars
maximum $2,000 for for a kid so it seems
only reasonable once you pass a certain
threshold of of child support that um
that the the the financial provider
should be able to you know at least
recuperate some of the free some of the
money that he's he's already paid taxes
on or her has already paid taxes on
anyone who hasn't asked a question
yet representative Nelson thank you Mr
Speaker uh no actually I mean M I'm so
sorry Mr chairman
you got it you got a promotion I promot
sorry about I'm sorry about that thank
you for taking my question um my husband
pay child support for a very long time
and um and his ended well before 2018
but um just for my curiosity and
reference can you is like do you know
like what um how do I find out about
researching like that because I don't
recall us ever taking a deduction on our
taxes when we were filed
uh married and filing
together it it should have been in the
um uh in the decree and part of the um
uh uh either the parenting plan so one
one of the three do or no it's the
universal support order it would be in
the Universal support order um who gets
to claim the child on what
year um followup please follow up
followup yes um so so that's I'm
confused I'm sorry I'm just trying to
sort through this I'm confused because
um taking a tax credit versus taking a
deduction for the amount of money that
you paid in child support are different
so is I'm not I'm confused about what
you're saying
actually uh is there a question yes
could you could you please um clarify um
whether you're talking about a tax
credit or a deduction for the total
amount that you pay in child support per
year yes so tax deductions as I said
before do not exist anymore since 2018
so there's no such thing as as a tax
deduction for for um a a child for for
child support you can only um you can
only get a child tax credit that's it
okay thank
you sorry representative Raymond I'm
sorry representative George has had her
hand up as well she has I didn't see
that representative
George thank you um Mr
chairman um I just want to know because
I know there is a lot um parents
sometime the woman that like the one who
in custody take care of the kids okay
and uh you know how much for someone who
take care of can be two child three
child yourself do you know how much that
person is making for take care of all
those kids if the one pay charge support
just give like
$40 or $50 a month how much that the
person who I take care of the kids you
know how much is cost for
her um well I mean if if I as a man was
taking care of uh my child and I was
receiving uh child support you're you're
asking um how much my taking care of my
child is is worth then the
$50 yeah because when you take care of
the the the kids uh I'm sure the courts
would determine that based on the
financial avidid of the two parties and
that it's not the same for every person
like I said earlier uh children in our
state have different value some children
are worth more than others uh yeah I
know it's it's crazy but um the
otherwise there would be Universal child
support and it would be this child is
worth $20,000 a year and and that's it
so if you have one parent that makes $2
million their duty of support at least
that's what I'm hearing from the
committee would be not based on the
income of the parents in their financial
affidavit but that that base support
that monetary support of uh $220,000 I
guess is what I heard why isn't it based
on that it's it's not it's based on the
uh the income of of the parents the and
and the disparity of income between the
parents is how it's calculated and uh
now I'm not here to debate how how a uh
family court judge determines um how
much is owed in support by looking at
the burden on one party um who's taking
care of a child I would say in cases
where there's 50/50 which is a majority
of cases both parents would share that
burden equally so why does it matter I I
don't know but I'm simply here to say
the person that's that's um the primary
financial support provider should at the
very minimum because they're paying
taxes on the money to the recipient who
is not paying taxes on the money that's
being received ought to at least claim
the small tiny
benefit of of the child tax credit which
is maximum $2,000
I see one hand up representative
Malone thank you so can we go back to
definitions because you are saying
somebody that pays child support versus
Main Financial provider so someone can
pay child support and not be the Main
Financial provider so that's where I'm
getting confused because I felt like
that's what family court would do
whoever pays the most they would get to
claim that child that's how I've seen it
in the past but just because you pay
child support and I think maybe this is
clearing up does not mean that you are
the Main Financial supporter of that
child so is it just because you pay
child support or is it because you pay
more than 50% of that child's
income uh I would think that if you
weren't the primary Financial uh uh
provider you wouldn't be paying any
child support in fact I I you know I
don't I don't understand the specific
scenario that you're you're talking
about but if if a court um orders uh you
know it should be equal between the
parties based on you know based on um
whatever the the order is even if it's
not
5050 um you know one one party paying
the other the other party has still has
to pay taxes on on that money and the
recipient doesn't have to pay taxes so I
mean if if I was able to change the
legislation and make it so that you had
to pay the recipient had to pay the the
taxes on on the child support you know
that would be something that would be
something different but it the Dynamics
of of the law doesn't work that way so
this this is um all this to do is
correct what was changed in 2018 in
2018 the IRS was tired of of chasing uh
deadbeat parents uh who were claiming
the exemption but weren't actually
paying the child support so uh that's
that's why the the IRS changed its
statutes it it penalized um everybody
that pays child support cuz they can't
claim the exemption anymore because
there's a bunch of dead parents out
there and and it's not fair so this
seeks to at least remedy that since we
seem to be asking now the same questions
I want to thank the representative for
presenting his bill because I have
another pink card before me okay and I'm
happy to stick around for everybody also
and the chair recognizes Mary krugger
from the Hampshire legal assistance and
you have written testimony
and Mr chairman I did distribute the
written testimony so I think everyone
has it now no we do not I handed it to
representative Malone and that's where
it's going we do not have it
yet but we soon will have it yet
terrific got stuck the chair recognizes
representative Grossman for passing
things to her left it was
a it was just red light oh did she think
the red light meant stop it did that's
what I thought
oh thank
you so I can I'll begin while people are
passing if that's okay all right just
move it along yeah um so U my name is
Mary Krueger I am an attorney with New
Hampshire legal assistance um we are a
Statewide nonprofit Law Firm um we um
represent low-income and aging clients
throughout New Hampshire in civil legal
cases so we um do what's commonly known
as legal aid or Poverty Law um and we're
very concerned we are opposed to this
the passage of um HB 322 especially um
for the lowincome population this could
really um cause issues for people um
often the uh people that we represent in
family law
cases we exclusively do um domestic
violence cases and we represent um
victims and survivors in high lethality
domestic violence cases um but often
both of the parties are living at or
below the poverty level um and so courts
right now can adjust um accordingly
who gets to um how the parties share who
gets to claim children as tax dependence
and
um I understand under this particular
Bill if the parties agree to do it a
certain way they can still do that um we
often have cases where parties they may
actually agree on that but they don't
agree maybe on a lot of other things so
they may be both um proposing to the
court that they share um you know often
splitting children in a particular way
to be fair um in different tax years um
but the court is making that decision
and making that order um if it is in
dispute the court um would not have the
ability to fairly determine especially
in cases where you have a like a $50 a
month child support uh order which you
know can be common it can often be a
fair low amount um and so this is a way
to sort of compensate um for parents to
be able to afford basic needs for their
children and so having this be a
mandatory um requirement would really
remove the ability for courts to fairly
allocate the resources which are often
Limited in the cases that we handle um
and so we are asking this committee to
vote no um to the passage of this Bill
thank you counselor any questions
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here um
I'm actually really glad that you're
here because my question is about court
and judges so I'm a child of divorce as
many people in my generation are and my
parents Switched Off year to year on who
get to got to claim myself and my
sisters are Judges doing that now like
making orders saying you get it this
year you get it that year are they able
to split up kids where maybe someone has
this child more and another child less
because of the child's needs do judges
currently make distinctions like that
yes all the time okay um it's very
common for judges to do that and then
they'll account for like if there's
three children you know they'll account
for kind of switching the one the third
child around and then they account for
what happens when they um are no longer
longer um you know the age out of being
a tax dependent depending on when that
happens they'll they'll write that into
the decree followup followup yes um if a
family situation changes so say um one
person has been paying child support but
he has a a he or she has a financial
change in their life like they've lost
their job or whatever do judges can
people go back to court and have judges
change currently who is doing the tax
credit or
whatever the orders are people can go
back to court on a child support um case
every three years by law or when there's
a substantial change in
circumstance um and they would be able
to request a change to who claims tax
dependence within that request to change
the child support order okay thank
you any additional
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you this ends the
hearing on House Bill
322 what do you
think I open the executive session now
on this bill and the chair calls on
representative rice for a
motion
322 that's all
right thank you Mr chairman I would like
to make the motion of itl on House Bill
322 and looking for a second
representative Greg thank you any
discussion among the committee
representative D Simone thank you Mr
chairman as a co-sponsor to this bill I
co-sponsored the bill because I thought
it might bring some relevance to the uh
to increasing the child support rsas
that would better what we currently have
um
I I thought it would strengthen our
child support in some way manner or form
by listening to the testimony of the
sponsor however in my opinion this bill
not only does not accomplish that but it
in fact decreases the value of our
current system and for that reason I
have to support the itl motion uh
100% other members of the committee wish
to speak speak on
this
representative
Le not pronouncing all the letters yes
um so I have many family members that
have stayed together gone um through
divorce and everything and um some of
them actually they would switch every
other year when who would file the kid
and when and each situation was
different and I think that the court
system and the parents can decide what's
best for their situation and um what's
best for them based on like financially
and who's more the stable parent who's
not and determin it that way that the
courts have been doing in the past and I
think that that has been working so far
if there is an issue I think that the
courts would come to us and tell us this
isn't working like they've had before in
situations thank you for your testimony
anyone else representative love
um our child support laws certainly need
work I think the judicial discretion uh
parts of our laws are way too strong but
this bill isn't it I'll be supporting
the itl thank
you anyone else
representative
georgees have to look thank you Mr
chairman um my testimony is uh like I'm
here as a cultural person too to show
like there is a some parent who are not
sometime they are here sometime they go
back to their country or what but they
don't they're going to say they don't
working you know or they they come here
they work just a little bit but where
they go over there they work they do lot
of work they do they make money but they
don't give it to the kids they don't
give it to the wife and I think so if uh
we support this that um to say like a
give them for the independent I think so
that to give give it there again more
money and I think so we don't that is my
testimony the motion before us on House
Bill 322 is in expedient to legislate
moved by representative rice and
seconded by representative Greg would
the clerk please call the
role
first yes and just to let everybody know
a yes vote is to the most
itl okay
yes yes microphone on
please representative rice yes
representative McMahon yes
representative
Nelson yes representative sidel yes
representative love yes representative
coren is yes representative marle yes
representative
Pedigo yes
grman yes representative
Levesque yes representative Greg yes
representative Raymond yes
representative georgees yes and
representative Malone
yes this is where representative Greg
has a question for the
chair is this going to go on consent
would you like it to go on consent
you've all consented thank you you
absolutely so this is on consent and uh
representative rice before the end of
the day would you please get your report
it goes first to me then to the clerks
and then wherever things go thank you
this ends the um executive session on
House Bill 322
next up is House Bill 325 we welcome
back representative Barton and the bill
is eliminating term and reimbursement
alimony and divorces granted on the
grounds of
irreconcilable differences and looks
like we have written
testimony
thank thank you Mr chairman
uh What U what's being passed around is
uh the 13th Amendment of the United
States
Constitution um and many of you should
be familiar with it um but we all have
Oaths to uphold the the Constitution and
I take mine seriously um the 13th
Amendment of the US Constitution
abolished uh slavery and involuntary
servitude what's
alimony alimony
is it's the the service the financial
service of of one party to another after
a marriage contract after the contract
has been completely dissolved it's
basically a court saying the the
contract between these two parties
specifically in ironable differences
cases or no fault cases that that the
contract be between the parties
um uh that that made it so one spouse
had a duty to the other spouse and vice
versa uh that that contract is null and
void but no you still have to keep uh
you this provision we're it's going to
survive the dissolution of that marriage
contract I'm going to make you uh um
spouse a a slave to spouse B
indefinitely you're going to have to
work and pay money even though you don't
know what duty of support to the other
spouse anymore because the marriage is
is dissolved so that's essentially what
what alimony is and um it ought to be uh
dissolved when the parties seek to have
the agreement that they made dissolved
um this again this is limited to no faal
divorces and irreconcilable differences
it's not um it's not restricted as um in
other in in four fault cases as a remedy
uh to make one spouse whole o over the
other I don't want don't want to go down
that road at all I think I think in
those cases um uh there should be
discretion um but in cases where the
marriage contract is dissolved by by
both parties there's absolutely no way
that one party should continue a marital
obligation to the other can you can you
imagine if and and if if you if you
don't have marital relations its grounds
for its grounds for divorce in our state
but can you imagine a judge or ordering
post divorce decree one party to provide
marital relations to the other party
it's absurd why should any provision of
a marital contract survive the
dissolution of that contract and why
would that not constitute involuntary uh
servitude um as described in the 13th
Amendment I'll take your
questions any question questions for the
representative representative rice thank
you very much Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question would you believe
that if a spouse supported one spouse
all the way through Medical School
through getting their license
establishing a successful
practice at the expense of them getting
a degree somewhere staying home raising
the children
Etc do you not believe they are owed for
the sacrifices they themselves have
made I I believe that the agreements
that are made between um I wouldn't want
to get into the agreements between a
party um you know if that's not part of
a marriage contract or or you know if a
spouse wants to voluntarily provide
something to another spouse you know
that that would be like a division of
assets thing or or you would look at the
debt I guess as far as as far as that
division there's no duty of support from
one spouse to another when the contract
is dissolved regardless of who who put
who through medical
school would you believe that that's one
of the main purposes of
alimony uh again no I wouldn't believe
that and I would think that it's
irrelevant seeing no further questions
thank you representative and uh I'm
searching for a pink card that would
accompany a
handout do you pass a pink card
down this is for the next it came with
the papers it did did you have the pink
card oh I might have it here here we
go yeah I've got
it all right so Nobody
Cries we're all going to take turns
being the roadblock so no one's feeling
it you're NE
R light is on
that's no you have another Duty
representative Greg is to remind me of
things the chair recognizes rep
uh Attorney Mary
Krueger by the way when I call somebody
representative it's not necessarily an
insult I won't take it that
way um thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you members of the committee my
name is Mary Krueger I'm an attorney
with New Hampshire Legal Assistant we
are a Statewide nonprofit Law Firm um
and we represent low-income clients and
um aging clients in civil legal cases
across New Hampshire we also operate our
domestic violence advocacy project where
we represent um victims and survivors in
Family Court getting protection orders
and in divorce and parenting cases uh we
oppose HB 325 and ask the committee um
to also um vote inexpedient to
legislate um there are three main
reasons one is that we believe this
would harm domestic violence survivors
especially um because Financial abuse
and control is um present in as many as
99% of domestic violence
relationships um I did attach to uh my
handouts um a fact sheet about financial
abuse which is something that's often
overlooked um when we think about
domestic abuse we often think about the
physical violence which is also um you
know ex can be extreme and concerning um
but the the financial abuse can often
keep a victim in a relationship um
because they don't see a way to be able
to afford to live especially when
there's children involved um and the
second reason is we believe that this
could increase the level of adversarial
divorces in New
Hampshire um and then our third reason
is that this will harm um especially
older spouses um who've sacrificed
careers um in order to stay home and
care for the family um and that that's
an agreement that often people will
reach and if they get divorced later in
life um they may not have been out
earning income paid income they've done
a lot of work um that's worth something
and um that's the reason why we have
alimony um and we worked really hard in
this committee I guess it was about 2018
to revise and update the alimony law in
order to have more predictability in the
way that courts can um
determine uh not only whether alimony
should be paid or um but also how much
and for how long um so that it's going
to reduce the level of
adversarial um proceedings in our court
system so that people are more likely to
come to the table and make
agreements um what this would do is not
only make it harder for domestic
violence survivors to leave knowing that
the financial control can continue and
if they um seek a divorce or the other
party seeks a divorce based on
irreconcilable differences or no fault
they're not entitled to request alimony
if this law would be passed so they
would have to plead fault grounds they
may have a basis for that but fault
grounds are extremely grueling to
prove um and it costs a lot of money um
you're going to be helping Finance
attorneys with this bill because people
will have to if they need alimony figure
out how to bring their fault case and
prove it um and it's a high High bar I
can tell you that in the work that we do
we don't have a lot of cases where we
have high earners on the other side
because we're we're representing
low-income people but every now and then
we'll have a very extreme Financial
abuse type situation where there's a
high ear or on the other side we may not
opt to do fault grounds because of the
traumatic um situation that this can
cause for somebody to have to go through
a fault case it's not good for anybody
involved to have to prove a fall case um
there may be reasons to do that um there
may be good reasons to do that um but if
you can have the option of no fault and
know that you can have the support that
you are entitled to because you have put
so much effort into um keeping the
family um raising the children keeping
the home all of the
things um that people sacrif I to do for
their for their own personal reasons and
then they have nothing when they get
divorced because they haven't been out
in the world to earn and that's that is
the purpose of the alimony is to to to
help have some fairness and the last
thing I'll say about that is the alimony
law that we have right now the first
step is for the court to see does the
person seeking alimony have a need for
that alimony and the court needs to
analyze that um they can look at the
earning capacity of that person their
education their background all of those
things to determine if they have a need
if they say yes then they look at the
other party's ability to
pay and that's after they're meeting you
know their reasonable expenses and you
sort of look at the lifestyle that the
parties have been accustomed to and you
know that people reasonably need to
adjust that when they're splitting
up and then we apply a formula in order
to figure out the amount and the
duration the duration half the length of
the
marriage so you're married for 20 years
you get 10 years of alimony if you
qualify okay so say you're 40 years old
you've stayed home 20 years of ing
children you get 10 years of alimony
so that's just the practical way that it
operates that this legislature and this
committee passed in order to have a fair
way to handle this issue so this this
would completely dismantle it and that's
why we ask you in expedient to legislate
thank
you some of us in this committee were
also members of the special committee on
the Family Division of circuit court and
as such we at least one day and a few of
us more than one day shadowed family
court and we saw the various things in
real time on the ground that take place
in these kinds of
matters would this bill take away judges
discretion in some way by simply saying
this is
eliminated well the judges would not be
able to order money unless there were
fault
grounds that were proven and so with the
fault grounds that's very much in the
judge's discretion to determine whether
there are fault grounds I see I've asked
my question backwards sorry okay but it
would in your
experience heighten the number of
divorces that are no longer no fault but
divorces for cause which in your
experience is time effort and money to
prove yes thank you it would heighten it
if we think back 50 years before we had
no fault divorce I mean people had to if
they wanted to get divorced figure out
who's going to take the hit on fault
right and now we've got to prove it so
like they might agree to it but um
you're not you know there are there are
New Hampshire Supreme Court cases that
we have back in the 1800s where people
didn't get their divorce because they
couldn't prove fault I mean it is a very
high bar which is why we have no fault
um so you will have people who need
alimony to live trying to figure out how
to squeeze their situation into a fault
ground and that's that's sort of where
we were 50 years ago how do we squeeze
the situation into a fault ground so I
can get divorce
questions for the counselor
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so I'm thinking about a
hypothetical situation but this is what
happens with actually a lot of people
that I know where the marriage has run
its course and both parties have agreed
that they want to get divorced it's not
a high conflict divorce they're they're
in agreement they want to get divorced
and they on their own have decided that
because one spouse is either unemployed
from raising kids or underemployed that
the other spouse wants to provide
alimony would the changes to this bill
eliminate that possibility because it
says that the judge can only order
alimony in divorce cases decreed in
favor of the innocent party so would
that impact these people who have
already decided on their own that they
that this is the arrangement they want
with their spouse that they still like
they just don't want to be married to
anymore I'm just reading it again so it
says the court May order May order term
alimony solely this would be the new
language solely in divorce cases decreed
in favor of the innocent party under
4587 comma upon agreement of the parties
so I think the parties could
agree under this
and if I could just add I think parties
do agree that that definitely happens
and I think we were Chang the law in
order to make it easier for them to
predict what alimony would be what the
obligation would be it's the cases where
people proceed on irreconcilable
differences and one party requests
alimony and there's not agreement about
that and maybe some other things like
property Division and other things like
that and so the court is having to hear
that case and that's the case where then
you're going to for sure see people now
pleading fault probably both
directions right I think this this this
um committee has Heard lots of testimony
from the court about the 10 to 15% of
divorce cases that take up all their
time yeah so thank you representative
Marquel you are an attorney would you
care to weigh in on this bill um yes Mr
chairman thank you I can
um we get that on there okay uh I happen
to agree with your testimony attorney
Krueger and uh fall grounds are
exceedingly difficult to prove as a
practicing attorney I can tell you
that's been my experience and uh this
would unduly restrict A party's right to
be able to to be able to ask and receive
alimony um I'm also uh with respectfully
disagreeing with your the prior
witness's testimony I am unaware that
the United States Supreme Court court or
any court has ever has ever decreed has
ever decided that alimony constitutes a
violation of the 13th Amendment to the
Federal Constitution or the New
Hampshire Constitution for that matter
um uh so I would support this and um
when it comes time for to execute this
bill we can weigh in at that
time anyone else with a
question seeing none thank you very much
for Testimony counselor and this
concludes the hearing on House Bill
325 open the hearing no I don't I open
the executive session on House Bill
325 and the chair calls on
representative marel for a motion okay
thank you Mr chairman um I move that we
decide that this bill is inexpedient to
legislate and for for the
second representative
Grossman
discussion representative D Simone where
you pronounce all the letters for those
of you who are new by the way we had
this discussion last term that in
Italian you pronounce all the letters in
French you don't so and thank you for
representative Petrino for bringing this
to the committee's attention sir thank
you thank thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for that tutorial on our names
it makes it easier for us to
pronounce um again I I co-sponsored this
bill because I always believe that
there's room to
enhance uh a particular RSA when it
comes
to helping people through some of the
most difficult times in their family
life uh it is now uh
my to my knowledge that this bill does
not in any way manner or form enhance
any of the laws that we have I am
plagued with the thought that somebody
thinks that paying alimony is Tad amount
to
slavery I don't know where that thought
process came from and I'm not going to
question it but what I do question is
that when you marry it is a
contract in business when you enter into
a
contract like with a marriage contract
there is
a an uncertain date sometimes as to how
the length of that contract and a
marriage contract is usually an unspoken
Lifetime and when that contract is
broken sometimes a person needs help
getting themselves back on track
again that's one of the reasons for
alimony in business you buy out the
contract I don't think that the other
party is being bought out but I think
that if you want to relate a contract to
a contract that's the only way you could
coldly do it without
feeling men and women who are in a
contract with their
partner deserve the opportunity to be
educated or have the time
to get a job that
will help support themselves and their
family and that's what alimon is all
about therefore I
100% um support the itl
motion thank you Mr chairman other
comments representative Georges thank
you chairman um I just want to this is
just my testimony for
myself because for the things
um I was divor I I did a lot of
work but 20 after 20
years I was just um my ex-husband was
asking
divorce but what they cot did everything
like just they didn't give me anything
not the harmony but I was paying I I was
not working I was going to school I was
paying the I was pay the mortgage I was
I was taking of the kids and the only
one things I was just getting the social
security for the kids but when those
kids become 18 it was just when2 one
just come 18 after one year and then and
another one I stay with but I never get
the Almon but I suffer and I see all
those women and that man we all the
money we was making by the was building
the the the house in their country
because we are not the same country I
come from Africa I come from hi he build
a big house there and now stay nowal
with another the woman and he was sick
he was in a car accident I support
everything I can't the doctor even said
for me now going to work because I need
to support him but they never gave him
Harmony and suff I think so I'm going to
be with those women they need to give
them har money because this is is not
something think um we can just accept
because uh to eliminate uh I'm just with
our support it thank you thank you
representative anyone else
representative
Nelson thank you Mr
chairman um this isn't just
um exclusive to women receiving alimony
it's the opposite way too and I just
wanted to make that clear for the
record I know of a few instance
of that anyone else representative
love thank you Mr chair
um I think we ought to be real careful
as far as
uh putting laws together and voting on
laws that encourage divorce uh you know
this uh without this we're we're
encouraging uh what happened to me you
know I was working 16 hours a day uh I
got hurt uh couldn't provide the the
financials uh you know the financial uh
for the for the home and um you know my
my ex-wife came up and said I'm not
having fun anymore we're
done okay uh where would that leave a
guy like me um you know I I I think this
is a good idea but I I'm I'm you know I
don't like alimony I think it should be
an individual uh
agreement you know uh you know in each
in each individual divorce um you know
if if it if it fits fine and if it
doesn't but there there's no
fault uh no fault divorce is has has
been a a a a burden to the to to society
in my eyes you know uh and to
uh I think I think this would be a a
step in the right direction but uh you
know probably needs needs some work
needs some work but um you know uh I'll
be I'll be voting for The itl but uh i'
I'd like to see something with uh
something like this that uh we could we
could work on and uh and come up with
something better than what we have by
way of example and a positive shout out
representativ Spain has been bringing
bills on the same topic three or four
times now because we would say close but
no
cigar which was not a put down it was we
can't vote for it just yet and take the
testimony that we all made and come back
and he's come back and I think this time
we may one or more of his bills make it
so maybe that is the case with this and
some other bills um and anything any
thoughts that you have to any thoughts
that any of us have for the prime
sponsor of this to possibly make this
passible another time I'm sure this
Prime sponsor would would welcome that
um anyone else uh representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman I think one thing
that we've talked about certainly when
we um were on the special committee on
Family Court
and within this um I almost said this
chamber I don't know what this whatever
this room we've had a lot of discussions
about the separation between what we do
legislatively and what the Judiciary
does and certainly when we're talking
about alimony we're talking about things
like this this is a on siiz fits none
situation so really leaving that to the
discretion of the judge the judge does
not always award alimony that's just not
100% thing and I think that that's
really where that still
belongs thank you we're going to take
anybody who hasn't testified yet and
then you get another shot at it okay
anybody else who hasn't while
representative georgees is pondering her
second fight at the Apple representative
marel do you wish to weigh in briefly on
this um but well uh I think the bill is
an expedient to
legislate um it's difficult to implement
uh as uh attorney uh Mary Krueger
pointed out and in my experience
litigating divorce matters fault grounds
are exceedingly difficult to prove they
also have in in terms of implementing
them it's not only that you pled F
grounds there have to be certain other
statutory com uh factors that have to
play into it as well and for a court to
consider it the approximate cause of the
breakdown of the marriage this would
make it exceedingly difficult and um I
don't think it's it's going to solve any
problems so I would renew my motion for
an
itl one more representative
George thank you chairman um I just was
try to make sure to there is a lot of um
people sometime they don't even know
much about the law and about all those
things for the divorce like when I went
to for the divorce I didn't know every
anything but to to help
people like when I was at this time I
think so for today I know a lot of
things but at the time I didn't even
know what what I supposed to do what I
who can help me we are here to help the
the community the people like this thank
you representative
grman thank you chairman Pearson and
just to pick you back on what the
representative was
saying alimony can be associated with
such a dirty word and until someone
begins that process it's restorative it
is not meant to be negative it's meant
to be restorative however on the way
that many people look at it it's like
this bad thing however when we look at
the process and the meaning for it and
if someone was at home raising
children
um overly qualified with a master M's
degree you know there should be some
discretion whether alimony should be
awarded after 20 years or not so um I
will uh not support this
bill the motion before us on House Bill
325 eliminating term and reimbursement
alimon and divorces granted on grounds
of irreconcilable differences moved by
representative marel and seconded by
representative Gman would one of the
clerks call the role
please chairman Pearson yes this is yes
to itl or no to itl it is the negative
motion so yes sorry representative
deimon
yes representative rice yes
representative MCM yes representative
Nelson says yes representative sidel yes
representative
love representative Coen yes
representative marel yes representative
patrino yes representative Gman yes
representative LC yes representative
Greg yes representative Raymond yes
representative georgees yes
representative
Malone
yes uh unanimous
16 to
zero the motion of itl is unanimously
approved 16
to0 why let's see would we like it on
consent yes we would thank you for
asking so goes to consent this um
concludes the executive session on House
Bill 325 and since we have uh
approximately 50 15 minutes those clocks
are fast that one especially uh with the
permission with the encouragement of the
ranking member I open an executive
session on House
Bill uh on 70 from last week which was
chairman muffet's bill this bill removes
military retirement benefits from
property settlement agreements as a
result of the dissolution of the
marriage in the state of New Hampshire
and I'm trying to think who was lined up
to make that
motion
uh I don't remember either but I can
find out ah yes it was representative
Mar thank you Mr chairman I move would
you care to make a motion yes sir thank
you Mr chairman I move that we
uh declare that to be itl inexpedient to
legislate thank you sir and
representative
Raymond and now we may discuss
it and I will say that um I've had a
conversation with the prime sponsor he
understands the concerns that we have in
um with this bill
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman I think that uh we voiced and
um discussed some of these concerns last
time but it kind of is on theme with
where we are today it's the same
situation with alimony um being that
military spouses have an even larger um
burden as far as you know moving not
being able to work all these things and
so this is a necessary thing and as
representative grman so eloquently said
this is about restorative things when a
marriage fails and so um this bill
troubles me that it would take away that
restorative
feature thank you representative any
further
comments representative Raymond thank
you um I I agree I also want to just
point out that um I think that as the
chairman was saying earlier there are
some bills that people listen to what we
have to say and then they come back with
a A change I I think in this case um
part of the issue was that
um that this was a one-size fits all or
one size fits none um so I think if
someone came back and said we want a
bill that would have judicial training
so that the judges know that it doesn't
have to be 50/50 it can be case
dependent that would be something that I
could get behind um because judges do
have discretion and they shouldn't be
doing 5050 in every case they should be
looking at all of these um criteria that
are set out by um the US uh former
spouse protection act and so I I would
love to um not just quash the idea of
making changes that help people but like
really focusing on how do we make the
changes so that they apply to a VI a
wide variety of circumstances and not
just one person's
experience representative
love thank you Mr chair yeah I won't be
voting for the itl uh for the reason
it's not a pension uh even though it
says pension up the top uh we we heard
that it's a
retainer okay meaning uh you know uh if
you and I had a contract I I retain the
right to call you back to work and here
here's some money for for you to do you
know for us to to uh to do that contract
um we're not talking about uh alimony
we're not talking about child support
this is just a
uh it's it's not property you know as as
a as a a pension would be or um you know
IRAs and things like that uh this is a
this is still an an an active act that
this that the retiree has to has to uh
he's obligated to you it's the
government um you know they're they're
uh they're restricted to their conduct
mandates could cause them to lose it uh
that their employment uh they can't they
can't go overseas and work for as one uh
one guy said uh work for Saudi Arabia uh
you know without approval this isn't
just a a plain everyday retirement
account that uh that so many of us are
used to this is something much different
and um you know like I said I'll be
voting against the
itl anyone else wish to speak to
this representative George thank you
chairman
um I think so except for if there is a
for the good
cause and um like um the chairman D said
for
50/50 to look
what um they are going through and then
what they do all for the like the
property they they cannot put that like
the pension inside if they give
everything because I see like it's a lot
for one person for me that I see like
it's a lot for one person they can go
50/50 representative
marel
um well I can respectfully disagree it
is a pension um even though it was
characterized as not being a pension it
also requires the equivalent of a
qualified Domestic Relations order to be
able to transfer the retire the plan
participants interest to the alternate
paye um so it has to go through a
specific military process for it and
it's rather
complicated um so the other thing is in
closing is is that it's only one part of
the marital pie in New Hampshire when
people marry virtually everything they
have which is both assets and debts
enters into the marital mix the uh
pension rights in military are only one
aspect of it and to separate that out I
think is going to undermine the purposes
of these of the present statutes so I
respectfully renew my uh motion to
itet thank you anyone
else seeing
none the motion before us is on House
Bill 170 relative to the division of
military pensions during divorce
proceedings and it was moved by
representative Mel and seconded by
representative uh Raymond and when ready
the CH the clerk may call the role
please chairman Pearson motion is itl
yes chair uh representative D Simone yes
representative rice yes representative
McMahon yes representative Nelson yes
representative sidel yes representative
love representative cour is yes
representative marel yes representative
patrino yes representative Gman yes
representative Levesque yes
representative Greg yes representative
Raymond representative georgees yes
representative Malone
yes 15 to1 15 to one the itl motion
passes
it can go on consent with uh the
approval of the negative vote otherwise
you get to write a
report
okay uh don't consider that a threat
just a
promise uh on to consent then yes uh and
this concludes the exec session on House
Bill uh 170 before we move on to the
next uh Bill uh this meeting is there
reserv every Tuesday morning with the
chairs and the vice chairs and
apparently there's been all manner of
breach or proper deorum and etiquette in
some committees and as this was being
mentioned I'm sitting there saying nope
not us nope not us isn't it fun even
when we disagree to work well together
that's what we try to do here folks so
thank you I'm sitting there saying can I
put my hand up and say that's not us and
I just decided not to because I think
our reputation is is yes a golden
star all right moving along open the
hearing on House Bill
433 in four minutes thank you I was
looking at the clock after I said it's
too fast thank you
actually
e
e e
AR and removing the language regarding
age waivers from Marriage registration
records since age waivers are no longer
issued in New Hampshire the chair
recognizes representative Margaret dry
the prime
sponsor thank you Mr chairman and thank
you committee for hearing this bill for
the record I'm representative Margaret
dry I represent Sullivan County district
and I'm here
today because life throws
curveballs experiences in my own family
and
friends uh of parties being married at
17 years of age have convinced me that
sometimes that is an option that
works when the marriage bill passed last
year raising the age of 18 of marriage
to 18 with no exceptions I immediately
thought of exceptions where it might
might be nice to at least have an option
on the table and one exception that
immediately struck me as reasonable and
logical is those on active duty in the
military this exception shows up for
example in the state of Alaska where the
age of marriage is 18 but there is an
exception for those on active duty
military the age
of uh being able to support a child or
being have to support a child medically
or by child support in our own New
Hampshire
statutes declare that that stops when
someone becomes 18 becomes emancipated
or is on active duty in the military
that triumphant appears in other places
in our law where people are considered
adult by being either over 18
emancipated minor or an active duty in
the
military all branches of the Armed
Forces
have 17 as the minimum age for
recruitment military benefits such as me
medical coverage and insurance are only
given to spouses not to girlfriends not
to fiance only spouses can get housing
or accompany those stationed
overseas I sent two sons to Iraq in the
Marine
Corps I realized as I watched them leave
the house that there was a very real
chance that they might not come
home we have a volunteer military now
but if we ever do have a draft marriage
might be an option that some would like
to
choose this bill has been crafted as
narrowly as
possible at least one party has to be
active duty military at least one party
has to be a New Hampshire resident we
don't want New Hampshire to be Las Vegas
where people come just to get married
and any party who is not on active duty
military but is 17 must have parental
consent there may be people here today
that call this child marriage because
you're
17 but I have never heard a 17-year-old
Soldier be called Child
Soldier persons in New Hampshire can
give consent for sexual contact with
adults at age
16 but marriages for bidden until
18 that's quite a disconnect we consider
16-year-olds old enough to consent to
sex but don't consider 17-year-olds old
enough to consent to
marriage I have received a bulk email
from all over the US asking me not to
bring child abuse back to New Hampshire
well perhaps the age of consent law is
the child abuse and the ability to marry
in the case for example of pregnancy
would be child protection that is
protecting and providing for the child
that is on the
way I am not changing the law in New
Hampshire this bill does not repeal last
year's bill I repeat this does not
change the law it merely adds a narrowly
crafted
exemption providing an option for those
who put their lives on the line for our
country to provide
for the ones they love and I asked you
to vote this bill ought to pass and I
would be happy to answer any questions
thank you representative any questions
for the prime sponsor representative
LC um since the thank you Mr whatever I
am yeah sorry thank you Mr chairman
chairman oh thank you sorry I haven't
had that much coffee
yet it's in the other room um since the
marriage law has been in effect for um
30 days yet do you see that this bill is
necessary or do you think that we should
give this more time to get into effect
so that way if there is a problem we can
address it next next term well if you
rem thank you for the question if you
remember last year that was an attempt
uh attempted um there were some
attempted amendments at this and there
were exceptions brought up that would
like to been added to this I felt at the
time that it was just um a cut off
without much discussion about whether
there could be some exemptions uh so I'm
thinking that while it is new and there
this is a good time to add
exemptions
followup and do you see an issue when it
comes to if the couple do get married
and then try to get a divorce and due to
the um
service members civil re Relief act
could come into effect when it comes to
them being overseas and their partner is
trying to get a divorce and divorce
proceedings have to be on hold until
that member comes back and I don't want
to think it but some members May extend
their um deployment so that way they
don't have to get a
divorce thank you for the question I
think that's a worst case scenario and
I'm looking at there will be other cases
that'll be better
scenarios other questions representative
Raymond um I I actually oh thank you Mr
chairman goodness it would just happened
too I don't know where my brain is today
only two weeks
back so thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I appreciate
it um my question is about active uh
duty military and and so uh it says on
in the bill very many times active duty
and I don't know the definition of
active duty and I wondered if you could
explain it does that count like basic
training or is it not till after like at
what point does active duty start starts
with basic training okay so is it as
soon as you've signed the recruitment
letter or after you have been sent down
to wherever you're going that's a better
question for somebody who might have
military experience okay I'll ask when
they come up then thank
you representative georgees thank you
chairman um thank you taking my question
I just uh you know some there is some
kids
um graduate like at a 17 years old and
there isas not to everybody because I
know all my kids most of my kids just
have a uh graduate 18 but the youngest
graduate in 17 but not every kids
finish his school at 17 that the reason
maybe he cannot go to the military but
if he graduate 17 that he can go to the
military and for you you think so the 17
years old girl she's really with a mind
to to take care of really the
family she can take care of the family
to be
married well I think she should have the
ability to make that decision
she doesn't have to choose to do this
but the ability is there to make a
choice to get married and she needs
parental consent if she's
17 follow up one followup yep thank you
um I
know she she have ability but not
everyone the problem is if one can do it
not to all of them some some of the kids
are not really
mature that that is a problem too it's
for one person can be very smart can
just go do everything but not all all of
them this is this is the problem we
canot just please make sure this is a
question the testimony can be for the
exact session this is to elicit answers
from whoever is at the chair okay I'm
sorry just my question just like again
second week we're
new
representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question representative dry
would you believe that I left my
household at 17 years of age and I
cohabited with a an abuser and I was not
able to um seek help as I was a a minor
and would this enable somebody to seek
help if they are of married
status okay could you repeat that again
I'm not sure how this relates to this so
thank you I'm sorry okay thank you for
the question so what I'm saying is that
um when we um when we voted on the um
the age of marriage being raised to to
18 17y olds no longer are able to go to
a a domestic violence shelter um and be
cared for um without uh being afraid
afraid of especially if they're young
mothers of of being separated from their
infant because she would go to one
foster home and the child would go to
another however um my question is um if
a if that 17-year-old mother is
emancipated she would have the same
rights as a a person in the age of
majority is that
correct I'm I believe so but that really
is not tied to this this is not Bill
part of the bill make sure you're
questions are about this bill for active
duty military folks other questions
representative LC um so with the active
duty thank you Mr chairman uh with the
active duty military um I looked at your
bill and it doesn't specify an age limit
when it comes to active duty military
because um just doing a little bit of
research beforehand most of the military
branches go between the ages of 17 and
42 and is there any like would you
consider having a age stop for this bill
so that way we don't have a 42y old man
or a woman marrying a 17-year-old
child the idea is that thank you for the
question this this bill makes this
active duty person an exception to the
18year um minimum they would be then
17 okay because that's the the year that
you can be in the military but not yet
have reached the age of marriageability
in New
Hampshire representative Petrino thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question I could have missed it and I
apologize if I did but what is the
motivation uh behind the legislation in
terms of making an exception for someone
who was 17 just because they're in the
military I mean why not make an
exception for all 17-year-olds you're 17
you're in love you want to get married
so I could have missed it but what do
you think thank you for the question
well some of this came from my
experience as a military mom and
understanding U kind of what you leave
behind when you go overseas uh both of
my sons saw um active duty in the war in
Iraq and it was very troubling for um
the family left behind I think that it
we are very fortunate that it is a
volunteer military right now but uh at
the time I was looking into this things
were heating up in the Middle East and
things were heating up in Ukraine and
the the word draft floated around a
little bit and I realized that if we
wanted to allow this exception for for a
time when there was a draft the wheels
of government move very slowly and uh it
would I would rather have something on
the books I'm not expecting a landslide
of people to come who are 17 marrying
17-year-old milit active duty military
but I would like this option to be here
on the
books representative D
Simone thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking my
question taking into consideration your
statement about um the age of 16 as the
age of consent and uh I'd like to move
you forward to this type of a scenario
uh you're 17 years old you're engaging
in that behavior with an 18-year-old
military man who or woman who goes off
overseas or to another part of the
country a pregnancy takes
place the military person may not be
back in your vicinity for two to God
knows how many years the child is born
and now doesn't know the other parent
the other parent doesn't have any
interaction with that child on a regular
basis can't hug them hold them walk the
floors at night with them what kind of
an impact do
you possibly believe there could be not
only on the
adults quote unquote but the
child thank you for the question if I
understand it you're asking the benefit
to the child and this person and I
couldn't understand if they were married
I'm asking you if they were not married
they would not be able to the the mother
would not be able to be on the same base
as the military
person or in the other case the
father the mother could be on base give
birth to the child and the father
wouldn't be able to be on base if if he
were 17 so I'm asking you what how
detrimental would that be to the child
and the family unit later on because
they may not be able to marry for four
to six or eight years thank you for the
question now I understand yes I uh I
believe this is not only in the benefit
for the physical um material benefits
that come with marriage um including
insurance and medical insurance um but I
just realize how much the the benefits
of Housing and being maybe perhaps able
to Eon accomodate um someone traveling
overseas uh makes a difference soldiers
think about home when they're not in the
United States um and if they're provided
for well at home I think they rest a
little bit easier and I think that yes
you I agree that there more goes beyond
just kind of um physical benefits but
there are things like housing that you
you need to consider and how strict the
military really is about it being a
spouse thank
you thank you representative for your
testimony thank you because I have a Mt
full of cards I will exercise my right
as the chairman of this committee to
limit every subsequent testimony to
three minutes 3 minutes means
180 seconds at 2:45 I will let you know
2:45
and at 3 I'll shut your mic off now this
should not be a problem most of you have
requested three minutes or less and last
term the best speech I have ever heard
in nine years in the house was 47
seconds it was precise it was on point
it was compelling with that the chair
recognizes representative Katie
Pell to speak
good morning chairman Pearson and
members of the committee thank you um
for the record I'm Katie Pell I
represent the towns of walboro and
Tuftonboro and a representative dry told
me about this bill just yesterday and I
thought oh that's definitely something I
can get behind I know a perfect example
of why this bill would be necessary in a
very small number of situations but as I
was listening to her testimony it
occurred to me that this is a really
beneficial Bill also to our military and
I'll I'll give use my story as an
example of why that is I have a friend
who um found out when he was 18 that he
had fathered a child when he was 15 at
the same time as he was turning 18 he
discovered he had fathered another
child and he was doing drugs and getting
into all kinds of trouble so now he had
two children and he needed a to provide
for his
family and the way out was to join the
Navy and he was able to provide for his
family and have an exceptional military
career in the Navy in fact he almost
retired at one point or left the Navy at
one point went into recruiting realized
he had fallen back in love with the Navy
and continued out his 20 years and um
bears that um very proudly so I think
think this is a situation where it is
helpful to a very small number of people
in this person in this situation but
could also help somebody out of a very
challenging life situation I mean and we
have declining enrollment in the
military and we need we need these young
men willing to step up and if they have
a family that gives them motivation to
step up and serve their country and take
care of their
families thank you any questions for the
representative
none thank you for your testimony the
chair recognizes major Shelly is it Hoy
Hoy fellow Air Force Major thank you for
your
service and the hardest thing is to
remember to turn on your mic Bingo now
the clock starts thank you Mr chairman
good morning for the record I'm Shelley
hoik a retired major in the United
States Air Force I live in Hoppington
New Hampshire I'm here to speak in
opposition to the proposal that would
allow New Hampshire children to marry
military service members I'll will speak
to three of the unique realities of
military life which make this proposal
dangerous for our children the transient
lifestyle of military service the
uniform code of military Justice and the
financial pressure faced by Young
military families the life of a military
service member is transient and
unpredictable in my first two years in
the Air Force I had five permanent outof
State moves the shortest was 6 weeks in
D duration and the longest long EST
distance was okaa Japan this is relevant
because every time a military spouse
arrives at a new Duty station he or she
is completely isolated until he or she
creates her own support system of
friends in a new community this support
system is your lifeline when your
service member is called away can you
imagine being a 17-year-old child
hundreds or thousands of miles away from
everything and everyone you know trying
to develop a network of friends she
won't be successful when the military
memb away she will literally be home
alone for months at a time what if the
military member isn't deployed but is
abusive this happens in the military to
whom can the child spouse turn for help
you're thinking call the police that
brings me to my second point of military
life the mum J military law is different
from civilian law in that a service
members Commander has sole discretion of
whether and how to punish any crime
committed by that service member on base
I volunteered with the great crisis
Council when I was stationed in okanawa
Japan I saw firsthand how commanders
make the decision of whether and how to
punish members of their own team I
specifically recall the case of a female
marine who was raped in her own bed the
facts were uncontested the male broke
into her lock dorm room while she was
sleeping and had forceable sex with her
there was no prior relationship and she
did everything right screamed for help
called the police
fought her attacker immed um submitted
to the exam and filed a complaint I was
there when the decision was made not to
punish her attacker no lawyers judges or
police were present the commander opted
not to pursue the punishment because it
would unfairly Mar the clearing record
of a marine who had a promising career
if this is how they respond to violence
on one of their own a fellow Marine how
high do you think a commander is going
to Value the well-being of a 17-year-old
child from New Hampshire the third
relevant reality of military life is
consistent
245 the third reality is the financial
struggle that these people face when
they're
young military member a 17-year old
without a high school diploma or with
one is not going to be able to compete
for an on-based job time thank you for
hearing my testimony and any questions
for the
major I think I have to awake up now
representative
Gman thank you chairman and thank you so
much for being here and for your service
um as well and just a comment to thank
you for that and for your testimony and
when I was born on a military base in
Germany my dad was in Okinawa so I
appreciate that thank
you thank you for the any other
questions
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you so much for
testifying and taking my question so I'm
going to go back to the when does active
it says in the law the language says
active duty so when does that start does
that start when you go to the Air Force
Academy does it start when you finish
basic training like at what point is
this person active thank you for the
question um in my understanding is that
the day that you show up at the me
station for this is for enlisted person
when you show up at the me station you
raise your hand and you're sworn in and
then you get on the bus to go straight
to basic training that's the moment when
your active duty a a Cadet in the armed
um I'm sorry in in the school service
schools sorry um is is not active duty
and they're not allowed to marry until
they graduate okay I'm sorry I might be
wrong about whether they are active duty
but they are cadets and they're not
allowed to marry until they grad wait
follow up follow up thank you so um so I
guess my question is then procedurally
how would that work if someone is
wanting to get married to their High
School boyfriend or girlfriend but the
person has to go off to basic if they're
not if they're active when they get
sworn in but then they have to literally
get on a bus and leave is there a is
there amount of time in
between or is it they have to wait till
the six or eight weeks of training is
done I'm not sure whether I mean there
are moments and hours that you're
waiting for the bus after you sign in
there could be a special
logistical I I can't answer that
intelligently I'm sorry thank you I'm
sorry it's been I'm old enough that it's
been quite some years since my high
school boyfriend joined the Coast Guard
and I don't remember how it worked I
don't think I went with him to the
swearing in so thank you any other
questions okay your backlighted yes
there you are representative LC thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for your
service um my dad was a Air Force bet
and um he enjoyed it very much um my
question is uh so when you sign up for
the military there you give you were
given like a stack of paperwork which
can be overwhelming um in there uh is
there a paperwork that you can sign that
list anybody as the beneficiary to
receive the
benefits um for from the military you're
testing my memory thank you for the
question um as I recall it doesn't
happen until after you get to basic
training you go to a whole bunch of
different classes and in each one you
learn about a new form and so it's
during basic training that you assign
beneficiaries in in my long
ago
experience thank you major thank you for
your testimony and for your service
chair recognizes representative Terry
Roy followed by Emma savini followed by
representative Harry
Bean morning Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you uh representative
Terry Rory Rockingham 32 chairman of
Criminal Justice I here as a co-sponsor
of the bill today and here to testify on
behalf of the bill to be clear I don't
think getting married at 17 is a great
idea I think if we had the power we
should maybe make it 35 before you can
get married um maybe older um having
said that November 13th 1986 I was 17
years old I reported to the me station
for basic training I was 17 I was um I
just finished high school I was um young
for my for my class one of the youngest
in my class uh my first Duty station I
was sent over to West Germany country
that doesn't even exist anymore um
that's how old I am I'm older than some
countri
having said that um I was um not
probably smart but lucky I didn't I
would wasn't wasn't married didn't need
to be married but I can see the reason
for this exception and I would urge
members who fought so hard for the
18-year-old not to see this as chipping
away at your work or or loosening it
this is a very fine exception whereby if
a
soldier goes to basic training um
sometimes there is a break in basic
training I heard the question question
brought up I went to basic training in
November we had I forgot what the term
was but at Christmas we had a break and
we went home for 2 weeks and we had to
go back which was horrific I wish they
would have never done that um because it
was like starting basic training on day
one again having said that um there is
time before that and there's several
weeks usually before you get shipped off
to a duty station if you have the
unfortunate um luck that you made a bad
decision and your partner is pregnant
and you are getting shipped over to
another country for your duty station to
the other side of the planet she needs
medical care she needs prenatal care
that child's going to need medical care
and the military is not going to provide
it unless they're married um so this
that is so important to get that
prenatal care and to to have support for
her even if she can't go with you the
military has extensive support networks
to help single spouses that are back
there waiting for their soldiers so I I
would urge you to look at this from that
perspective this is to qualify it's
probably less than one tenth of 1% but
right now somewhere out there in New
Hampshire there might be a pregnant
woman right now wondering how she's
going to take care of this child uh
because her Soldier is is being sent
away so I would I would ask you to
consider it as that it's a narrow narrow
exception and I'll take any questions
any questions for the representative any
questions that don't relate to how old I
am or
1986 thank you for your testimony thank
you for your service representative
thank you next up is Emma savini
followed by representative Harry Bean
Emma savini from new
Futures good morning chairman and
members of the committee thank you for
having me today um for the record my
name is Emma savini I'm the children's
Behavior Health policy coordinator at
new Futures and we are here in
opposition to house
433 um new Futures is a nonpartisan
nonprofit organization that advocates
for the health and well of all Granite
Staters um we are here in opposition to
House Bill 433 because child marriage is
inherently dangerous and produces
devastating lifelong reper repercussions
to Children's Health mental well-being
and financial and E uh educational um
opportunities um child uh marriage
before a minor reaches the age of
majority clearly Falls in op uh
opposition to child's children's
Behavioral Health um strides that we've
made in our state in the past few years
emotional physical and sexual abuse are
are common in marriages that involve a
minor and these events are commonly
referred to adverse childhood
experiences or Aces Aces have lifelong
and devastating consequences um to an
individual's Health it's been linked to
things such as higher rates of substance
use disorder higher rates of suicidality
depression anxiety heart conditions
diabetes human trafficking um all of
these outcomes are only with four aces
um in your childhood or tied to only
four aces in your childhood the good
news is that aces are preventable and
New Hampshire has already done what
needs to be done to prevent Aces um in
child marriage by eliminating ex without
exception uh child marriage this
legislation would roll back roll back
that progress that we've made and so for
those reasons new Futures urges this
committee to vote itl on House Bill 433
happy to take any questions any
questions
seeing none is that a writing
or thank you for your testimony and my
love to Chloe as always you're
welcome representative Harry
Bean good morning Mr chair and committee
members I'm here in support of uh House
Bill
433 I think that it's uh necessary to
make sure that if somebody u under the
age of 18 that might be a parent because
the law is 16 you might be a parent when
you're 18 but if you can't get married
and you go off to war and God forbid you
get killed I'd like to see some kind of
um military support for the
family um
I got married um when I was
16 I've been married for almost 54
years um when I got married I quit
school and uh they said you'll never
make
it um I had two kids by the time I was
18 bought my first apartment house at
18 um my wife and I knew each other
pretty good but our parents who had to
sign legal consent for us to get married
knew us way better than anybody in this
room
guaranteed um without the parental
consent then it' be questionable maybe
but um so we've been married almost 54
years um bought Eight houses seven
duplexes two three apartment buildings
three four unit apartment buildings and
uh
she just left here with my great
grandson Harry bean I
6th we have three
children eight grandchildren and six
great
grandchildren marriage under the age of
18 works if the two people are
committed and the parents have to know
their children you know there are some
children that that not going to do it
but the parents ought to know that by
the the 16 they ought to know if the kid
is on the ball or if he isn't I would
think half a minute left rep yeah I'm
all done anyway all right thank you very
much you're welcome any
questions on how to be a great great
grandparent that
early
sorry thank you for your testimony
representative chair
recognizes uh Britney Wright flown in
from
91945 which is somewhere in California I
bet I've done bulk mailings before where
in California are you coming here
from thank you chair um San Diego oh big
military place yes okay clock starts go
ahead excuse me
chair Pearson Vice chair D Simone and
distinguished committee members thank
you for taking the time to discuss this
issue here today and what a p privilege
it is to participate in the systems that
allow each American's voice to be heard
my name is specialist Britney Wright and
I'm here to testify in strong opposition
to Bill HB
433 after years of abuse at the hands of
an adult man I was taken across state
lines and when I was recovered by the
police my parents for forced me into a
marriage to my childhood
abuser I escaped at 18 and the divorce
left me homeless with no one to turn to
for help except the greatest military
force this world has ever
known I put my nose to the grindstone as
they say and with multiple attempts I
passed my GED and I joined the United
States Army Military Police Corps where
I served seven
years signing a contract with the
military gave me access to expansive
training and resources that I still use
to this day training and resources that
have made me stronger healthier have
made me a better mother and they have
given me an education training and
resources a married emancipated minor
does not receive as a result of signing
a legally binding contract that is a
marriage
license child marriage gave my abuser an
adult man who at the
time was in the
military the power to groom molest and
rape me at 14 years old take me across
which is a which is a class B felony in
the state of New
Hampshire take me across state lines
without the consent of my Guardians
which is a class a felony in the state
of New
Hampshire marry me at 17 years old and
walk away from a number of criminal
charges with a child bride he could then
legally
rape when we allow child marriage under
any exception we allow grooming to take
place in our society
period every military member serves for
their own
reason like my father and my grandfather
before me I serve because I love this
country and I served to rebuild the life
that child marriage stole from
me and I still serve my country here
today
by standing up for the most vulnerable
among
us next time you think a thank a
military member for their service
remember me and remember my
story seconds do not thank me for my
service if you plan to use it as an
excuse to justify the abuses that occur
if we allow child marriage in our
society under any circumstances under
any exception time is up any qu
representative Greg first of all this
sincerus thank you for your service and
for your bravery in telling your story I
know that's not easy oh thank you Mr
chairman for letting me do this and
thank you for taking my question so just
to clarify at 17 your parents signed
permission for you to marry
someone thank you representative yes
that is correct children do not consent
to marriage their parents consent to
marriage
I was listening to
your genuinely heart-rending story and I
wonder would it not been pretty similar
if you were actually 12 months
older that's a fair question and yes
because I would have then been illegal
adult which would have meant which would
have meant that I had access to divorce
which would have meant that I would have
had Access to Health Care without the
permission of my spouse MH who was
clearly not interested in my
well-being thank you thank you chair any
other
questions representative D
Simon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you so much for taking my
question after you turned 18 how long
before you divorced
the horrible
person six
months followup
followup thank you if you'll take a
followup are you aware that in New
Hampshire you can file for divorce at 17
I am aware thank
you seeing no other questions uh thank
you for your
testimony chair recognizing is Aaron
Hearn from Hansen
Massachusetts that is or was a base was
it it
is thank you Mr chairman uh hansam is
but we're on the the south side of
Boston ah similar in
name thank you very much Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is Aon
Hearn and I work alongside Unchained at
last as a volunteer
maintaining New Hampshire's ban on child
marriage is not about maturity we know
that turning 18 does not suddenly endow
someone with Newfound wisdom however as
mentioned previously on their 18th
birthday individuals do gain all the
rights of adulthood that they did not
have the day before this is especially
important in cases where a minor might
be forced into marriage a minor being
forced to marry a service member can't
simply open the door and run away to
avoid that forced marriage a minor who
runs away from home repeatedly can be
deemed a child in need of services and
summoned to a court hearing to determine
further intervention even if they could
run away there's nowhere for them to go
Advocates who provide Direct Services to
these minors have found that domestic
Ser domestic violence shelters across
the US routinely turn away unaccompanied
miners even emancipated
Miners youth shelters are also not a
solution as they're not confidential and
typically only allow a 21-day stay as
their main goal is to reunite the minors
with their parents who may have been the
ones to force them into to this child
marriage while an adult in this
situation could retain an attorney to
help them figure out their complex legal
needs a minor cannot because contracts
with miners are voidable miners are not
even allowed to bring legal action
independently as you've heard miners are
automatically emancipated upon marriage
gaining limited adult rights however
these rights do not prevent forced
marriages which can typically mean being
removed from school and raped on her
wedding night the trauma of such
experiences cannot be erased by granting
a man IP ation that is why all child
marriage is globally recognized as forc
marriage because miners lack the
necessary legal rights to enter a
contract as serious as marriage when
girls facing forced marriages seek help
from direct service providers like
Unchained at last they often dis
discover their legal options are very
limited their desperation can sometimes
lead to self harm or even attempted
suicide as they see no other way to
escape what feels like an unbearable
situation for these reasons I ask that
you oppose HB 433 and I thank you very
much for your time and
consideration thank you for your
testimony do we have any
questions thank you for
coming chair recognizes that he has
elderly eyes and may not get the first
name right so it is Ms rice and you can
fill me in on that first name please
the first name is Fredy but it's a
misnomer because I'm Not Afraid um Fredy
like a Fredy cat without the cat you
have come all the way from Westfield New
Jersey for today I have thank you for
coming thank you so I'm here as a
Survivor I'm a forc marriage Survivor so
this is very personal for me I'm here as
an advocate from my traumatic experience
I founded Unchained at last to end force
and child marriage in the US including
here in New Hampshire and I'm here as an
expert my research and writing on this
issue have been published extensively I
ear Ur you to vote no on HB 433 let's
not undo the progress we made last year
when we ended child marriage in New
Hampshire first of all child marriage
and a military contacts is dangerous we
at Unchained have worked with many
survivors who were forced as minors to
marry service members at age 17 forced
to marry a service member why should a
girl in that situation get any less
protection than a girl being forced to
marry a civilian I can't think of any
reason child marriage is associated with
high rates of domestic violence and you
heard a little bit here from firsthand
accounts and others um how hard it is to
get help in a domestic violence
situation in the military so not only is
it the the police situation reporting it
but also think about the fact that
military spouses um can be alienated
from their family and friends because
they move frequently and so it becomes
very hard for them to develop that that
uh circle of trust that they need to get
help in a domestic violence situation um
and you heard here before somebody
testify a child marriage works 70 to 80%
divorce rate child marriage does not
work it's unlikely this is going to work
out highly likely that this girl is
going to need help and not be able to
get it on a military base now um and you
also heard how hard it is to serve a
service member so if this girl wants to
get divorced how trapped she can become
even though she's technically
emancipated and has the rights of
adulthood now child marriage in a
military context also is unnecessary you
heard about that heartbreaking situation
uh a girl Mar a girls not married to her
boyfriend who deploys and he dies in
service to this country and now she's
left destitute you can assign your death
benefits and your life insurance in the
military to anyone you want regardless
of your marital status you don't have to
marry for that reason and um for a
17-year-old who needs health and housing
resources we should never ever write
legislation that encourages or requires
girls in that terrible situation to
marry service members so that they can
get these resources they deserve and can
get resources that do not require them
to enter into an adult sexual
relationship with lifelong repercussions
and of course the service members
benefits would extend to their children
regardless of their marital status now
bringing back marriage at age 17 even if
it's only the slight little um you know
exception for military also would bring
back the legal trafficking of minors
under the guise of marriage and that's
because federal law doesn't specify a
minimum age for marriage instead it
defers to state law and so that means
17-year-olds in the state would again be
allowed to be trafficked for their
citizenship 15 seconds left in myif last
15 seconds I will say you heard about
Alaska having a military exception to
the marriage age that is a law that was
written in 1975 and has not been updated
other than Alaska we don't know of a
single state in the entire world with a
military exception to the marriage age
the Dark Ages have called they want the
thank you for your testimony
I I gave you several seconds M um you
welcome and I'm New Jersey it was a long
term uh any questions
beeny Jersey
yeah any question
okay we will be executing this bill
sometime in the future but not today
this ends the hearing on House Bill 433
please be back at 1
1:00 and we'll have some more fun thank
you
e
e e
I open the hearing on House Bill 478
establishing a foster care over site
committee within the oversight
Commission on children's services flown
in at Great expense from his normal seat
up here is the uh pride of um Milford
the Hampshire representative
pisho thank you Mr chairman and thank
you my my colleagues on children and
family law so uh I present House Bill
478 to establish a permanent foster care
oversight
subcommittee um within the oversight
Commission on uh children services uh
now this legislation originated from a
bill we had last year that sailed
through this committee nicely and
throughout the process and that was
Senate Bill
566 and that formed a study foster care
uh families and we had some uh members
representative diamone uh representative
Alicia Greg and myself along with
Senator Shannon chandley and we met over
the uh Summer from August through
October we held eight meetings and at
which time we heard testimony from um uh
DCF uh we heard testimonies from the
office of the child advocate various
children Advocates such as uh the
children's Law Center and Waypoint we uh
we met with and interviewed and heard
testimony from current and um former
foster parents and and what we heard was
that a lot of foster parents are feeling
isolated they're feeling lonely they're
feeling that the children's needs are
not being met uh a lot feel that they
have a lack of support they reported
dysfunction within the agency uh
problems with the courts and so we heard
the testimony we took we took it very
seriously in fact the senator and I even
met with some Milford constituents in a
coffee shop because they were unable to
attend and we heard their testimony as
well so the bottom line is after a lot
of work that we did over the summer it
was recommended that we put forth this
bill so that we can continue to hear uh
the needs of foster parents and also to
maintain oversight over DCF in this
regard so with that
I'll entertain any questions thank you
very
much seeing none thank you come on
back chair
recognizes Lista masi sorry Lisa masio
and Cassandra Sanchez from OCA
good afternoon hello it's been a long
time nice to see you all for the record
Cassandra Sanchez child advocate for the
State of New
Hampshire and I am Lisa massio associate
child advocate I thought we knew each
other better Sir with my
name Lista I don't normally is my
handwriting that bad greet You by
looking at your foreheads I know trying
to protect you all um we are here on uh
to support this bill um I did attend
most of the the sessions this summer
with representative deimon and
representative patrino and
representative
Greg oh oh she's not there okay I was
like where is she um so and we had also
reached out in our networks and had met
with a bunch of foster um parent uh
groups they meet kind of informally
there's Facebook groups and we had
reached out to them via Facebook to
invite them so we all also got a lot of
feedback not everyone could make it to
the committee but that there was um a
lot of discourse that they would like to
be having so we do feel like this would
be nice to create this space within the
oversight Commission on children's
services specifically because that body
already Hears A lot of these same issues
but from a more systemic level um so it
would be really nice to create this
space for foster parents specifically to
be able to come and feel like they can
share that with a group that is really
dedic ated to listening to these issues
so we just wanted to share that
perspective from having attended this
summer and and I just want to add very
briefly um that we heard from those
foster parents that they really
appreciated the attention and the time
um they were feeling a lack of support
by the division um I recently have not
heard that same level of concern but I
know at that time it was very heightened
there was a a lot of um needs that they
had that weren't being met and so having
the space to be heard um made them feel
valued in their role and want to
continue and attention of our foster
parents is critical to the safety and
well-being of our children and so we
want to support that however
possible thank you any questions for the
good folks from
OCA seeing none mask up and thank you
very much
sir now let's see who I can recognize by
foreheads
here chair recognizes Susan larabe and
Jennifer Ross from dcyx
F there you are all
right halfway through you have to swap
okay good or we could share a seat too
good afternoon Susan laraby general
counsel and legislative liaison for DCF
good afternoon Jennifer Ross deputy
director for DCF we really don't have
any testimony to provide today um we are
not in opposition to this bill um as
many know in this room we have worked
tirelessly to improve especially this
over the summer going to these meetings
hearing from the foster parents what
they need because it's not only about
retaining um I'm sorry about recruiting
these foster parents especially now with
kinship care and recruiting these uh
special kinship Care Homes but retaining
them working with them to make them feel
supported so we have no no opposition to
have a a a community oversight of
helping us working with us and problem
solving and working to the good of
recruiting and retaining these uh very
special pieces of this complicated
puzzle would it be your opinion that the
quality work done by this subcommittee
would be akin to the quality work done
by the subcommittees for me who chair
DHHS oversight that oversight
subcommittees are a good thing with that
your testimony that would be my
testimony I was hoping so yes
great yes I agree oh anything else you
want to give us no we
are time even though we got a late lunch
so any questions for the folks on
DHHS no great thank you just remember
we've moved DHHS oversight to 100 p.m.
and it will be the third Friday of
February because the fourth Friday is
New Hampshire school vacation so if you
have any business before my oversight
committee it's 1 pm on the 3D
Friday of February great okay thank you
good okay thank you so much I have no
other cards uh on
478 so I close the hearing and I'm
willing to bet that my ranking member
will have no objection to move to
oversight you see no objection I open
the executive session on House Bill 478
establishing a foster care oversight
committee within the oversight
Commission on children's services and I
am going to call on representative
Petrino for a motion thank you Mr
chairman I move UT to pass on House Bill
478 and I will second
it
now any further discussion during our
time together on this
everybody looks so
happy
well in fact even one of our happy
members is ecstatic with
joy she wants
me why that would be representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman um I really think
that this uh um is it a commission
committee whatever that we're
establishing is very important I sat on
the
on the foster care special committee
over the summer and it it felt like that
that bowl of pasta the more we dug into
it the more there was and so it's uh
it's certainly a challenging thing but a
very very important thing so I'm happy
to support
this representative D
Simon thank you Mr chair although I Echo
uh both representative patrino and
representative Greg sentiments I also
want to say that I'll use a different
analogy there are so many layers to the
foster care program and we've added two
more layers with the kinship and fictive
care that I think that this type of a
subcommittee on that commission is
absolutely necessary for us to be able
to learn and and help um the department
learn what good we can do with these
foster care programs I was in in a
meeting
yesterday and we were talking about the
need for more Foster families to keep
kids out of placement in
particular
facilities so if we're going to keep the
kids out of those facilities and put
them in loving caring
homes I think this will do it thank you
Mr chair
yes representative
Malone so I have been a foster mom as
well as a kinship provider here in New
Hampshire for 25 years anything that we
can do to promote the strength and the
support that Foster families get is just
going to strengthen the system most
Foster families they're trying really
hard to reunite these children with
their families which means they have to
have training on on trauma that comes
from these families being able to not
hold a grudge against biof families when
you see some of the reports that come
through and it's not easy um your
children also go through this vicarious
trauma that the other children have come
into your house um so again whether
they're related and I've done both um I
just had my last one just aged out she's
going to be with us until she's 20
because she took the after care um
that's
provided 25 years ago we barely had any
support as Foster families and we even
stopped doing it for a while because it
felt like you did not know where you
belong so I think this is
incredible my point earlier
um oversight committees I think have a
lot of Great Value because you bring
people with various aspects of the
subject together in the same room and
there's a lot of cross fertilization
what is lost however sometimes is so
many of us have become generalists a
specific subject doesn't get dealt with
to the depth it's it is needed and I
think by having a subcommittee under
this oversight committee you have the
advantage of both um a large synthetic
way of looking at things but also going
deep into specific things and I found in
my oversight committee which is da HHS
uh this to be the
case seeing no further comments the bill
before us is House Bill
478 establishing a foster care oversight
committee within the oversight
Commission on children's services moved
by representative Petrino seconded by
representative M Pearson and would the
clerk please call the role
chairman PE yes representative D Simone
yes representative rice yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
sidel yes representative love yes
representative coren yes representative
Markle yes representative patrino yes
representative grman yes representative
l
ask representative Greg yes
representative
Raymond representative georgees yes
representative Malone
yes 15 to one no it is not uh 15 To None
sorry 15 to none with one
absence and I've got a great idea we
could put this one on consent any
objections
no objection so onto consent it goes and
representative Petrino if you haven't
already written your report on this
please do so and pass it along before
you leave
tonight we have um our next uh that
closes the executive session on 478 our
next up is
553 and we must wait exactly 6 minutes
before we
start um as often as the case and I have
one of these tomorrow
the bill that you we have all looked
at is often replaced in whole or part by
an
amendment and that's important because
sometimes the things we didn't like in a
particular Bill the amendment has taken
out so I would suggest in the five and a
half minutes we have left you should
have in front of you 2025-the
Bill
553 and I would suggest you read it over
representative Greg who will be
introducing the bill will speak to this
when it is her turn to but in the
meantime let's read it
over wow look at
and just while you're reading it over
and not chatting amongst yourselves um
this Amendment only replaces one section
of it so note that this is not a replace
all
Amendment no it's
not
e
e e
I open the hearing on House Bill
553 an act relative to the definition of
abuse and neglect and conditions
triggering a rebuttable presumption of
harm in abuse in neglect cases with the
prime sponsor our very own
representative Greg thank you chairman
Pearson and thank you fellow committee
members um for the record my name is
Alicia Greg I represent national award 7
I'm proud to be here before you today um
I would first like to point to the
amendment that we have
here um which is
OS had the bill apparently there were
some miscommunications and came out with
some things that um not only myself but
also the um stakeholders that we talked
to in the original committee that worked
on this did not agree to so we this is
just taking that back to the original
language that was agreed upon um this
particular Bill comes from a study
committee uh headed by Senator Carson
and also former Senator Whitley it had
actually our own representative McMahon
on it as well they worked very hard this
last year and trying to figure out what
we could do to update our definitions of
child abuse and neglect and that's where
this language comes from with a little
bit more refinement afterwards there are
few things that can bring people
together like the protection of children
what we are gathered here today to
discuss is that very
topic when we first looked at this bill
when I first got this bill there was
some discussion amongst people do we
name this bill do we name it after some
of our most tragic cases that have been
in the news certainly not the most
tragic overall but the ones that we hear
about Javon Riley Briel Gage Buu vaugh
Elijah Lewis Harmony Montgomery or any
of our broken babies the possib list of
polic abilities is far too long
ultimately we decided that this bill
once it gets amended and refined belongs
to all kids in the granite state I've
sat with many of you on different
committees the committee looking at DCF
the committee looking at family courts
and Foster Care one thing that is
glaringly important is that something is
missing far too many kids are ending up
incredibly
hurt so when we look at our bills that
we have before this committee 169c I
like to refer to as kind of our Holy
Grail it's the child protection act and
anytime we want to open that up and look
at it it's a big deal and it has to come
with the highest level of attention and
that's what's happened for 45 years this
has sat with not a good or um robust
revision on what defines abuse and
neglect in our state while we continue
to make attempts to Band-Aid or correct
what we already have we have yet to go
back to this foundational piece it's
kind of like if you have a foundation of
a house that can continues to crumble
and you just put new sighting on it's
never actually going to work that
sighting is going to pop off
everything's going to be unstable we
have to go back to the foundation and
that's something that until this we
haven't done it now this was attempted
last year I believe it was Senate Bill
459 we had these definitions a lot of
this language is very similar with one
big change had a very large fiscal note
on it this one while it does have a
fiscal note still listed will have no
fiscal note this has no cost um which is
great on this slim budget
year now I look back because I thought
45 years first of all I was a little
shocked that 1980 was 45 years ago um so
I had to double check
myself but believe it or not it was and
I was definitely old enough and if
you're my age or close to you might
remember when you could ride on the
middle hump in the car or I even rode in
my grandma's back window
and that was okay then we knew that it
was okay and this is 1980 this is when
this language was first
devised but the thing is when we know
better we do better we've had a lot of
advancements we've had a lot more
learning about what happens with
kids so after I got this language from
Senator Carson it was incredibly
important for me to go to the
stakeholders that had been a part of
those conversations one by one and say
what is your input on this let's
here hours and hours and hours this last
fall actually I think this is so
important I waited to give it to my
co-sponsors until I had a more refined
language from the people that work in
this day in and day out now we have a
really exceptional position here in the
children and family law because we get
to hear from all of these stakeholders
so while one particular group might be
very focused on one area of the law is
our job to look at all focuses and not
just to say well we want to make make
sure we hone this in on one thing and
not the others what the child protection
act does is it says the kids this is
about child protection this bill is a
civil bill because it's a civil matter
this is just about definitions of child
abuse and neglect this is not
prosecutory this is not about the
criminal side of it that's something
different this is just about the
definitions um
and I understand that it's challenging
for somebody to come in and question our
parenting there's nothing more personal
than your parenting style there just
isn't that doesn't mean that what we're
doing is always right I have my own
personal experiencing having my
parenting
questioned and while it wasn't easy I
understood the necessity because I
wanted the safety of my children for
those of you that don't know I'm a
domestic violence Survivor
I also spend my time talking to groups
about what domestic violence is breaking
down those stigmas and really saying
what is it because believe it or not I
lived in it for 18 years and didn't
realize that it was a violent that it
was a domestic violent relationship I
just thought he was a jerk um and that I
probably needed to do a lot better that
I was getting punishment because I
wasn't worthy took me 18 years to figure
that out I never thought about the flip
side of that I specialized in helping
other victims and stuff until one time I
was taking um I was talking to a school
a trade school about what domestic
violence looks like and I had somebody
come up to me after and they said so I
think I'm an abuser could you please
talk to me and it's at that point I
realized and in talking to her
understanding that even though some
people don't realize they're being
controlled or what of sometimes we're
making decisions based on how we were
raised based on you know anything
hereditary and we don't understand that
we're making
complicating um decisions for our
children now we understand and we've had
trauma in form care we've had we heard
earlier about a scores we understand how
different childhood factors affect our
futures and that's why our committee is
so important and what we do on this bill
is so important because it shapes the
future of our community the children
that we have that we can protect today
are the children that will be our future
doctors our future scientists our future
sanitation workers our future nurses
there's no end to that they are our
future and their protection is of the
utmost important now in this in
legislatively we have all agreed that
the home is the best place to keep kids
this is also not about removing children
from the home this is about figuring out
how to get Services before we have
crisis
there have been so many testimonies I
have looked at DC the DCF workers in the
eye and questioned them quite fiercely
about why they're missing some certain
areas well when you look remember we
talked about that root part of it right
that Foundation when you look at the
standard that they are held to
currently we're holding them to a
standard without it without them having
the tools in their toolbox to be able to
do something a major crisis has to
almost happen before they can really do
anything and they're not coming in to
arrest people and further do that
they're trying to get services to people
because I guarantee you there are
parents that don't understand that even
though their their father and their
grandfather or their mother and their
grandmother did things that's not the
best practice now there are better ways
to do it we also have a generation of
kids that maybe have access and
understanding to things that we not have
and so sometimes it takes somebody to
come in and help us with that this is
about helping Granite State families to
remain a family to raise children in a
healthy manner that will help
them parenting is one of the most
important things we can do I actually
believe that our children are unone to
us and that our job is to guide them to
get them to that next step the child
protection act is incredibly important
piece of legislation and amending this
and updating the language to fit today's
needs is imperative we cannot continue
to let our children fall through the
cracks of a crumbling Foundation it is
time for us to take this Foundation
build it so then we can build off of
that but we need to have these
definitions updated will this fix all of
it oh no it's going to be that bowl of
pasta I talked about earlier and there's
going to be more but at least we have a
solid foundation to start with um there
are experts here that are going to talk
really specifically about each piece of
the language in this I'm happy to answer
any questions but I think when it comes
to specific I will let them handle it
because they're in the trenches working
this where we'll still kind of like
observing all of it so thank
you questions for the
representative representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman um my question is
actually for you sir can we ask about
the amendment at this time or only the
underlying Bill chair makes the ruling
that you may ask about the amendment
thank you can you speak to um what the
amendment changes from the original and
why it's important well originally the
language that we had and I kind of
touched on that earlier was a particular
way and um let me see let me get this
out here there were some specific things
left left out and specifically that we
left out that were added
um and I think that the office of the
child advocate would actually be better
to explain this but I do know that there
was one part that continued to flag that
actually um I believe she's here today
representative biman called me and said
this says in Udo and I'm like I don't
remember in utero anywhere in there and
then I went back and looked to see what
OS gave me and magically those two words
were in there so um that's something
that we did take out there's some
complicating things uh commas are
everything you'll see that there are
some commas changed because it
completely changes the meaning of of
that but I think that um the OCA will be
better equipped to answer all of those
questions because they're pretty uh
they're technical but it changes the
entire
thing thank you thank you Mr chairman
I'll wait for OCS okay representative
love thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my questions um in multiple
places here um we are using the using
the terms emotional and psychological um
abuse and stuff and that how was that
measured I think that would better be
explained by some experts but I do know
from my own personal experience with
emotional and psychological that's not
disagreeing with your kids um that
certainly we do disagree with our kids
we're allowed to disagree with our kids
even though my teenager would like to
think differently um it's about whenever
it it goes beyond that and it goes to
belittling it goes to damaging behavior
and so there are certainly a lot of
studies and stuff and I know that uh DCF
and OCA can probably talk and there
might even be a couple doctors that can
talk more to
that follow up Mr chair I have uh I have
multiple questions on this uh would it
be all right if
I let's do a few of them the most
important ones okay um the uh let's see
where am I are we talking about the
amendment or the bill both okay okay uh
we use the the terms preponderance of
the evidence of the evidence uh standard
rather than Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
Beyond a reasonable Doubt's been uh the
standard that courts have used for for
so not in as far as I understand not in
civil cases in criminal yes there is a
difference within civil cases um abuse
can be very hard to um Define and
certainly it's not always as clearcut
for every uh person that I've talked to
that has been a survivor of domestic
violence their counterpart has also
claimed abuse so it's it's one of those
things that you're not going to have um
that level of care and if we waited for
that level of care we'd have a lot more
in the situation that um the kiddos that
I listed I would like to ask for a uh
comment from attorney marel one of our
Representatives uh as a definition of
preponderance a one- sentence definition
is it more than 50% of the evidence
yes uh preponderance of the evidence
standard is simply more likely than not
get the ball over the net thank you you
know the Judiciary he wants me to go to
law school you know yeah okay
representative love
um I'll let somebody else ask and I'll
find the other things up that's that's
good okay anyone else
uh have you found one of them can you
wing it yes I have um good right at the
very beginning of the amendment uh it
talks about abandonment of the child for
how long what what are the age uh
structures for this um you know it's
different to leave a a a 2-year-old than
it is a 12-year-old uh letting the
12-year-old go play ball down behind the
school uh shouldn't be abandonment and
the way this is written it certainly
could be well absolutely and I think
that I will once again refer to the OCA
to that's a very specific um language
piece that was worked on by Senator
Carson and that committee along with
them so I'll let her I'll let uh the OCA
answer
that thank you
anything else for representative Greg
seeing nothing come on
back chair recognizes Brian Fleming um
police
officer from from
where okay thank
you sorry uh from
Manchester um good afternoon and thank
you for allowing me to speak today in
support of this bill uh my name is
Sergeant Brian fluming I'm with the
Manchester Police Department I'm the
sergeant in the juvenile unit um and we
handle the cases of child abuse neglect
and among other cases um for the past
seven of my 19-year career I've been
handling juvenile Cas related cases and
I believe anything that
will further the safety of children in
anything that we can do as a state is a
benefit
um I just prepared some uh notes here um
the bill takes important steps to
address the complex issues of child
abuse neglect by expanding the
definitions to include um crucial
aspects of a child's well-being such as
emotional and psychological harm
previously these often invisible forms
of abuse were difficult to address
within the legal framework but this bill
ensures these children will receive the
same protection as those that are
suffering from physical abuse because
often times you can see the physical
abuse obviously but you might not know
or be able to see necessarily
psychological and emotional
abuse um I also believe this bill will
help to give DCF the ability to get
Services into place earlier to hopefully
prevent anything from ever reaching the
criminal level where police involvement
becomes necessary I totally agree with
the statements that were just previously
said as far as keeping the family
together trying to support the family as
best as we can and we would rather see
as a police department the services that
are available out there through DCF and
other agencies help the families prior
to it reaching a police level or
criminal investigation so anything that
we can do to get early intervention into
these families into the with these
children to prevent anybody from getting
in trouble criminally uh we fully
support um the introduction of the
reputable presumption of harm is another
significant
Improvement um this provision recognizes
the inherent danger to children when
they're exposed to prevent parental
substance misuse impaired driving
domestic violence in the home or
oftentimes a serious unexplained injury
of a young child or
infant um by Shifting the burden of the
responsibility I'm Sorry by Shifting the
burden to the responsible party to
demonstrate the child's safety is not
compromise we or the other agencies out
there can intervene earlier and
potentially prevent any further harm to
the child um this bill also enlists a
trauma informed approach throughout the
child protection system while
emphasizing that the primary determinant
in these cases this the safety welfare
and best interest of the
child um this means doing whatever is
necessary to keep the kid safe and
recognizing the profound impact of
trauma on children and responding in
ways to help promote their healing and
resilience because the ultimate goal is
to make sure these children feel safe
and that they can grow
up feeling safe and become productive
members of society and be able to work
through whatever trauma they've had to
endure throughout their young
lives this bill also provides DCF with
clearer definition stronger legal
backing and a mandate for the
trauma-informed care ultimately leading
to a more to more effective
interventions and support for Children
and Families adding the specific
language um that's in there including
the psychological and emotional abuse um
Beyond just the term safety allows us to
be more clear as to what the child can
be protected under in my experiences
I've encountered numerous cases where
earlier intervention and a more
comprehensive understanding of abuse and
neglect could have made a significant
difference in the child's life but steps
weren't taken prior due to nothing being
in place to possibly protect that child
this bill provides the necessary
framework to prevent serious crimes and
ensures that all children have the
opportunity to
thrive off is it officer or uh Sergeant
Sergeant um thank you for coming while
we can imagine cases where intervention
did not happen in a timely way can you
speak to the frequency of when sincere
but misguided intervention took place in
other words uh the the family was was
put into a situation because of a
complaint that was not warranted and
there was harm done could you speak to
that one
Sergeant are you I just want to make
sure I have the question where Services
were put into place but they weren't
necessarily needed due the due to the no
I mean aggressive intervention in a
family that was wrong to have happened I
don't I don't necessarily know if I
could speak to that specifically as far
as like the inhome services and that
sort of stuff is what I'm trying to say
is have Agents come in like Gang Busters
into a family and uprooted and made
everybody cry and come to find out they
never should have done that have you
experiences of that
secondhand I personally have not I can't
say that it's never happened that
because I I wouldn't know off hand but I
have never been involved with a
situation such as that so is it true to
say that that scenario
is significantly dwarfed to the scenario
of intervention should have been done
but it wasn't in my opinion
yes thank you any other questions for
the
sergeant okay seeing none thank you and
thank you for your service Sergeant
thank you for allowing me to speak
today Mr chairman I do have one I'm
sorry okay he hadn't left yet so go for
no I saw him start to get up and then it
occurred to me thank thank you for
indulging me and and thank you for
sitting back down um have there been um
cases where the police were able to act
before DCF that you've experienced yes
um
in without getting into specifics we we
have responded to a call prior to DCF or
it came in through the police department
and we've encountered situations where
we've had to take the children but then
obviously we immediately call D DF and
they respond so there has been times
where we've gone out and acted prior to
DCF being notified okay follow up for
clarification have you had any cases
where the police have felt that a family
needs intervention to protect children
who were uh at risk of harm where DCF
was unable to enact um an intervention
because of the way the current
definitions work I don't believe so I
mean we've we've safety planned children
but we've always reached out to DCF to
get guidance and reach and they're very
quick to respond with us so if we've had
to intervene like that that they're
always either responding or following up
the next day okay or they're a part of
the safety plan that we're enacting
because we have to we typically let them
know if we're removing a child or
anything like that okay thank
you last call
thank you Sergeant thank you here's what
I'm going to do there were numbers of
technical questions asked of the bills
Prime sponsor and she said that she
would defer to some people who could
give technical answers I'm going to call
on those people first then I'm going to
call on any active state representatives
we have that is usual protocol and then
I'm going to deal with a whole stack of
pink cards I'm going to tell you ahead
of time anybody at that point will have
four minutes to
testify and as I said at a previous
hearing you can get a lot in four
minutes so if you have a script you may
want to cut out some things that is
unnecessary verbiage the best speech I
ever heard in this committee was 47
seconds long it was on point it made the
points well it answered a possible
objection 47 seconds we paid attention
I'm not saying that anybody in this room
starts losing interest in the middle of
a long speech because I don't think I
have to say that so if you have
something prepared I want to hear it but
it's going to be four minutes so with
that in mind I'd first like to call up
uh to provide answers to technical
questions that we've had um Cassandra
Sanchez and attorney Lisa masio from oia
good afternoon once again and for the
record Cassandra Sanchez child advocate
for the State of New Hampshire and your
faithful sidekick attorney Lisa masio
Lisa masio the associate child advocate
we do have written testimony that we are
sharing with you today um I will not
drown on and on about that um but I do
want to share in immediate response to
some of the questions asked um in
particularly the first question
from representative Raymond um yes we
have seen cases in which DCF was unable
to act when they wanted to um we did
some work with the field administrators
at DCF um a little over a year ago and
they sent us over 30 case examples where
they filed in court and the judge did
not uphold their finding therefore they
were unable to continue to service that
family and work with that family when
they truly felt those children were in
danger we learned of these concern
concerns because the field in DCF came
to the office of the child advocate and
asked for our help and said we don't
know what to do we are really worried
about these children but the courts are
saying we don't have enough how can we
protect these children they do offer
voluntary cases which they did in in
these instances and the majority of
those cases the families did not choose
to take because they did not want to
work with the agency I think it's very
important to highlight what
representative Greg had shared with us
that often times many families aren't
ready or aren't even aware that the
behaviors that are happening in the home
are unsafe to their children and so if
there's no willingness to take a service
how do we help them learn and grow so
that something detrimental does not
happen down the line that truly will
tear that family apart as mentioned it
is very critical in all of this that we
focus on maintaining families together
however whenever possible we as a state
have put a lot of attention and effort
into building out a children's of care
so that there are community- Based
Services able to to Ser as families as
opposed to Children needing to be
removed from the home to receive those
Services we have a very well wellb built
out children's system of care of course
we need to continue to fund this because
it is highly utilized right now in our
state but what that tells us is that our
families are benefiting from what has
been built but there are still families
who are slipping through the cracks and
that is what we are hoping that this
change in Lang anguage will catch these
is is not to bring in new families
involved with the division but this is
to service the very families that they
are already involved with they are
already receiving calls about they are
already assessing these families often
times time and time again because they
may not have enough the first time and a
couple of months later they get another
call couple of months later another call
may come in it may be a year but then
there is another call these are not new
families these are repeat families that
truly do need assistance and help but
again may not be aware of how to do that
and often times aren't aware of what is
out there in the community to seek it
out on their own so they need guidance
from a professional to show them what
can help their family and where they can
be down the road if they do take that
help it's also important to acknowledge
in this bill um as was said quite a bit
it is 45 years old there has been a lot
of psychological research that has
happened in that time frame a large
focus on Aces um if anybody's familiar
with this adverse childhood experience
is what we learn from adverse childhood
experiences the more of them that a
child has exposure to the more
likelihood they have of future health
issues down the road so we're not just
talking about mental health concerns
down the road although that is
absolutely a component of this but we're
talking about physical health outcomes
that are negative and there in
scientific research told us that but we
didn't necessarily have enough
information then there's a lot more work
done around trauma and understanding how
trauma impacts people throughout their
lifespan how trauma that happens as a
young child doesn't just live in your
childhood it follows you through the TR
trajectory of the rest of your life and
has a great impact on what you can do in
the future and by bringing this statue
into the current day and time to the
psychological research that really
touches on the importance of
psychological impact and Trauma to
children we can hopefully prevent some
of this and and truly that is the key it
is prevention work that it's going to
take to reduce these negative out out
comes we need to get into families early
on as we heard the sergeant just share
it's really important to have that early
intervention and by allowing the
division to file petitions based on
psychological abuse get into a household
teach those parents educate them
hopefully that's a one-time occurrence
that they need to touch that system and
they will never come back again because
they've learned from that but if we
don't allow that opportunity these
families do come back and back until
something terrible happens
and it's again this is for the entire
family unit the abuse of a child impacts
everybody around them particularly their
parents that we know care deeply about
them and want to see positive outcomes
yes there are some very horrific cases
we've seen with parents who did not have
great intentions for their children but
we know that is not most parents and we
know most parents are are truly fighting
to provide all that they can for their
children but we live in a very complex
world right now tensions are are high
generally for adults and so that
complicates life for children as well we
are seeing children with higher rates of
mental health diagnosis we are seeing
children higher rates of suicide um
suicide right now is the number two
cause of death in children 10 to 14
years old that is extremely young we
need our children they are our next
Generation um and so it is important
that we added in as well the um
definition of trauma-informed care uh
because what that means is that means
it's a system that's paying attention to
the trauma aware of it and responding to
people that way many parents who are
touching the system have also had their
own trauma we know generational trauma
is what leads many families into this
system and so having having trauma
informed Care at the heart of the work
that the agency does but now when
they're intervening and working with the
family they're not just looking at the
family and pointing a finger and saying
parent you're doing something wrong
they're saying we know you've been
through something let's figure out how
to get your entire family unit to a
better place and so we did work very
very hard to make sure that we found
thorough trauma-informed definitions
that came from psychologically backed
resources such as the national child
traumatic stress Network and absap ABAC
which is the American professional
Society on the abuse of children um two
very highly regarded National
organizations um and that so that is
where the definition in this bill came
from um you may have heard us as well um
speak in in this committee and other
committees in the past around a system
review mapping that we had um we had
held in the summer of 2023 and this
mapping was in regards to nine
non-ambulatory infants that presented to
EDS with multiple broken bones over a
4-month period that is a lot in a short
amount of time these children helped
inform multiple sections throughout
these revisions
I just want to talk for a minute about
the process of this bill as you know uh
last session uh representative Greg
mentioned it was s SP 459 which was
Senator Carson's Bill we had worked on
it for some time with the oversight
Commission on children's services she
had asked to retain it as a study
committee because there were some
discussions she wanted to have uh so I
did also pass around um for your guys
information the study committee report
and attached to it is the language that
senator Carson put forth and provided to
representative Greg as the language that
that committee had arrived at and
representative McMahon was on that
committee um and that language has been
agreed upon between the offic of child
advocate the oversight commission um
input that committee's input and dcyf
which was really important and was not
quite as clear with s459 there had been
some turnover in DCF so this was really
a collaborative process we sat at the
table with attorney larabie with Deputy
uh Ross with director Marie Nunan and
this language you have in front of you
with the amendment because there were
some errors in the original bill that
are corrected by the amendment this is
the agreed upon language and if you read
all of the minutes of the eight meetings
we had that were hours long each many of
these questions have been asked and
representative McMahon asked many of
them they really went through this bill
piece by piece and asked about every
word um and there were sometimes lengthy
discussions about one word or one comma
um of why things were worded that way
and those were discussions that were had
with us with other stakeholders in the
room with DCF uh Dr Amy Roy who you all
may be familiar with who have been here
for a few years is now actually the
director of the cap program at Dartmouth
Hitchcock unfortunately she's at a
conference right now well probably
fortunately for her she's in San Diego
so I just go off phone with her though
and she did sign in in support uh we
worked directly with her quite heavily
especially around the non-ambulatory
infant piece um Lieutenant Nicholas
georgis from Manchester um he sent his
his able Sergeant here today he's also
at a conference um also worked heavily
with us so um representative love I
really appreciate your question because
this is a common
misperception 169c is a civil statute
the preponderance of the evidence has
always the standard in Civil Court
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt is only used
in criminal proceedings the amendment
made in this bill is not a changed to
any law it's just a clarification
because the law was vague before it just
said insufficient evidence what does
that mean so we added the correct
standard of evidence in there because
otherwise it was very vague and unclear
um so a lot of the Amendments made here
were the culmination of com
conversations with many experts with the
experts at dcyf but I can tell you that
committee the study committee with
Senator Carson and Senator Whitley and
representative McMahon and
representative Robert hard was also on
it they asked incredibly detailed
questions um you know another section
I'd like to point you to that
representative Greg alluded to is right
at the beginning um on page one line 20
an edit was made to presume that family
Unity is in the best interest of the
child it used to say to determine if
preservation was we know from research
that preservation of the family unit is
in the best interest the purpose of this
bill and it um really aligns well with
sb47 from last session these were all
presented at the same time to maintain
that family Integrity but as other folks
have stated without the proper tools in
their belt without clear correct
thorough definition dcf's hands are
sometimes tied and it does escalate to a
point where the children do end up
having to get removed because this is
the 10th investigation now something
really serious has happened whereas if
we're able to see those interventions
earlier not after five or 10 assessments
you can preserve the family unit by
putting services in place so um I can
tell you that every word of this has
probably been discussed at length but
we're here to answer those questions for
you of what that process was like and
and one more addition that I I want to
point you to before we open it up two
questions um that you will see a very
Stark um difference in the amendment and
um the bill as introduced if you look
under neglect um in e um the as
introduced talks about exposure of a
child in utero um which was not the
intended language there um and now that
it has been fixed in the amendment um it
speaks to a child who is born substance
exposed um and what we found and our
understanding and through the research
as well is that it is really really
important to encourage mothers when they
are pregnant to seek care to seek all
prenatal care that they can receive and
unfortunately the way that had
previously been written it was not clear
that there are Protections in place for
mothers who are in treatment who are
taking taking medications to remain
clean from illicit substances and it's
really important that we encourage them
to do that so we worked to put language
in here that would ensure that when a
parent that it requires there to be more
than just the substance exposure by the
child which means oftentimes a positive
test at Birth rather than just a
positive test at Birth to have that
family be involved with the agency there
also needs to to be harm to the child we
do not want the hospitals to be calling
on every single parent who is trying to
do the right thing who is trying to stay
on their treatment plan we want to make
sure that there is truly a correlation
between their use and harm to the child
before the agency becomes involved so
that was a really important addition to
us and a way to help protect mothers and
ensure that they do seek out care
throughout their
pregnancy we are now open to questions
questions
representative love thank you Mr chair
thank you ladies for your uh your
testimony um I'd like to some
clarification on uh providing proper
supervision uh there's no no language
here for once again for for age
differences uh you know it's it's
different to leave a a two-year-old at
the at the ballpack to play baseball
than it is a 12 12y old um you know
there's there's no language here for
that and uh I I have a friend that uh
that was was arrested for a for his
8-year-old granddaughter who was sitting
at the park with her and her and her
brother and the kids are running around
there's a bunch of them and the the
8-year-old girl went up and over the
hill and uh some kid found her she she
got lost you know she was less than 100
yards away but uh he got arrested for
that some kids started yelling and
screaming and call the cops and uh he
got arrested and you know had to go to
court and pay a lawyer and all that and
uh you know where's the definition of
you know age related um requ there is no
age um intentionally in this because
developmental levels are drastically
different for each child so there could
be a child who is 10 years old who's
very self-sufficient there could be a
child who is 17 years old and is at the
level of a 5-year-old developmentally so
by assigning an age to that that could
become quite dangerous actually um
because often
times parents look at it like well if it
says here the age I'm going to follow
that to a te but if you're 1-year-old
truly is not safe to be home by
themselves then maybe we shouldn't be
following that or maybe we shouldn't
even have that in there because it
becomes a dangerous area in which we're
holding the parents to something that
the law actually contradicts so it's
really important to make sure we do not
assign an age but it is important for
the agency to be very reasonable and so
it's important to to know the process
what happens when somebody sees a child
and they think they're In Harm's Way
they pick up the phone and they call
dcyf and they somebody on the other end
of the phone from their Central intake
to take that report that person on the
other end of the phone who's taking in
this information is also looking at what
the abuse and neglect laws say oh you
got a 12-year-old they're by the park by
themselves mom was like in her car
getting something and came back that's
not going to screen in as abuse and
neglect to them they're going to say
sorry that's not us um we can guide you
to Community Resources if you're worried
about this family we can guide the
family to Community Resources but that's
not us we are not going to invest
investigate that we are going to move on
from that and so it is important that
there is that layer in between it is not
a call to DCF and somebody is
immediately knocking on your door there
is that in between of does this actually
meet the statute to say whether that is
something that they would open up DCF is
in the room so I would point to them um
to answer that question more
specifically about you know what they
think about when they're assessing for
that um for a child who's left home
alone I can say AB is quite different um
abandonment is truly a parent leaves and
there is no parent there to care for the
child to sign school documents to sign
medical documents they don't they're not
around that that is very different than
a young child a abandonment of even a
17-year-old is concerning because if
that child has a medical issue and they
need to seek care there's no Guardian to
sign off for that so abandonment is
separate from that issue but I do
believe dcif could speak better to when
they would screen those out versus when
they would
not followup is there any language that
you could recommend to bridge the the
difference right now no other than the
language that we have here um I again I
I'm I'm concerned about um adding too
much to the the definitions here to
really make it restrictive it does need
to be a bit more Broad and and a lot of
that additional work does come in DCF
updating policies after the fact as well
um and so the OCA works very closely
with them that whenever a bill is passed
um to ensure that the policy aligns with
the intent of the bill and the intent
here is not to overstep in those
instances I have a question for
Council yes sir it may be a
caricature that whenever a bill dripping
with compassion comes people say oh
that's a Democrat thing well I can drip
too but that's not my
point is it the case the four committee
members cited in this final report three
of them are
Republicans that is the case sir and
would you believe I'm not doing that to
to arh Horn I'm just trying to say that
this is not a partisan issue would you
agree yes and Senator Carson has frankly
been one of The staunchest Advocates and
supporters of the office of child
advocate she's chaired the oversight
commission since its Inception and she
has been pushing for this update it was
actually the committee that requested a
definition of trauma informed care and
that vetted this current language um
actually believe it may have been
representative McMahon who requested it
because we we all say trauma informed
care as though everyone knows what that
means um so that's where that definition
came from and and it has been a very
strongly bipartisan effort thank you
Council for taking my leading questions
anything else yes representative Coen
thank you Mr thank you Mr chair I'll get
the chairman speaker soon thank you Mr
chairman thank you uh thank you for
being here to answer my question um I
have a lot of questions about this bill
um but the one I want to raise now is in
the neglect section um the one that you
had just read paragraph E when the child
is born alcohol or substance exposed
except when taking as prescribed or
recommended and monitored by a licensed
healthc care provider and the newborn
child's health or welfare is threatened
by the use so the way you had just
explained it is you wouldn't step in
unless the child's health
was was compromised because of the drug
use in
utero um but from what I understand that
that's kind of
um luck of the draw um I've heard of
situations where you know two pregnant
women can do the same exact type of drug
and you'll have one baby born that's
perfectly fine
and then you'll have another baby who
was born with all kinds of issues from
the same exact drug use so why are we
automatically ruling one one family
out it's the importance of in in these
definitions it requires serious
impairment or harm to the child to be
able to file abuse and neglect in the
court to uphold that definition and so
realistically it it it is different
because where is the harm the harm is
not visible on infant a who mom
potentially had been using the child did
not exhibit any symptoms child B who may
have exhibited the symptoms now we have
harm and so it is important if we just
have these definitions that if you do
this to your
child the agency can intervene we're
talking about pulling in a lot of
families by the action it's how did that
action then directly harm the child and
so here we have made sure that there is
a tie back to harm to the child because
it is true and it is very strange we see
these often actually where we have cases
that have been called into DCF and one
child has absolutely no response to the
substance exposure and therefore they
close out but another family may not and
then they're servicing and working with
that family followup followup um so I'm
just I'm really comfortable letting one
parent off the hook because you know
their Their little bodies took it in a
different way than this little body but
both of those infants are still at risk
yes and so when those risk factors are
in place the agency can offer a
voluntary case to the family they can
offer them services to learn oftentimes
we actually see a a large response from
the hospitals as well sending home a a
VNA to continue to follow the child to
make sure that they're thriving and
those are ones where typically if they
do come back they'd be coming back from
a pediatrician or a daycare provider
down the line um but again if we it's
really hard to tie it just to the
actions of the parent because we'd have
a lot more families involved in our
system and truly our child abuse and and
neglect statutes always tie back to how
does that harm the
child I have a question uh my wife is a
family practice physician and I've spent
50 years is in part doing counseling and
she says it's much easier to measure
physical problems than it is
psychological problems and um she's
right and I suggested her for
analysis
uh how would we measure psychological
well-being it's quite difficult um to be
frank it is I acknowledge that um but
realistically we see it start to impact
different areas of a child's life often
so we're looking at how they interact
with peers how they interact around
their family members um how they
interact in a school setting and are
they struggling in different areas and
um also a lot a lot of children these
days want to talk to people and so we
find that a lot of our children are
either seeking out a therapist or maybe
a school guidance counselor and they're
able to talk about their experiences and
how it's impacting them and that's how
we learn so much about that impact of
trauma is through people sharing their
experience so when children open up and
share that and they're telling somebody
I'm may be suicidal now because of
things that have been going on in my
home that's going to flag for
particularly School folks if they're
told in that setting that's going to
flag for that school folk that something
is happening in that home and we likely
need to call it in and allow
professionals to assess that and then
the professionals also then go meet and
have a conversation with that child they
assess the whole family unit but then
they also separate that child and have a
conversation with them oneon-one and if
the child's saying I'm suffering with x
Y and Z because of what's happening in
my family unit then we need to believe
that to be true and we need to believe
that to be a psychological impact would
it be fair to say that there are certain
behaviors that are consistent which
doesn't prove it but it's consistent
Behavior to psychological abuse and that
various chapters in DSM and other places
point us to what those behaviors are now
that's not 100% correspondence but it is
enough is it enough then to go forward
with
investigation yes um because what our
behaviors they another way the child
communicates to us not all children have
verbal communication we need to read
everything non-verbal communication
behaviors it's all a form of
communication so yes there are some very
specific behaviors that are tied to very
serious issues such as um psychological
abuse there are very
specific um sorry sexual abuse they're
are very specific sexual reactive
Behavior
that can be seen from children um that
mirror child child can be somewhat
different but are pretty common to
happen in children and so that can tell
us a lot but there are other behaviors
as well that um coupled with other
information through an assessment do
tell us the child needs more growing age
regressive behaviors for example
absolutely okay counselor I just wanted
to add from my experience I was both a
DCF attorney so kind of Prosecuting
abuse and neglect cases in the Civil
courts as well as a parent attorney for
quite some time so the flip side of of
sort of expanding that language to
include emotional psychological mental
well-being is a call will often come in
with concrete indicators you know a
child is coming to school dirty hungry
very
tired and when there is
investigation there might not be the
physical indicators as sergeant Fleming
mentioned but there are a lot of
psychological indicators or well-being
indicators that that was sort of another
Gap that was being missed that children
are being exposed to trauma they are in
a neglectful situation but the way the
law was written 45 years ago they
weren't able to pursue and offer
services to that family unless there was
a indicator of their health or safety
versus all these psychological
indicators which are often behavioral
indicators so it's also that flip side
it's not necessarily someone calling in
of this child has a psychological
indicator it's more once you get in
there without that expansion of language
to recognize all the impacts of trauma
can sometimes be hard to pursue those
cases and they end up falling through
the crack and have multiple assessments
till things get really serious to a
child potentially being suicidal thank
you representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um one of the things that um
someone said a minute ago was about um
letting parents off the hook and so I
wanted to ask about what does it mean to
have services are we catching parents
are we punishing parents like what is
the services what's the purpose and what
are what's the array like well thank you
that is that's a great question um
really the services that are being
offered the services that that we as a
state have come behind are
evidence-based services that show us
that they have positive outcomes and
most of those evidence-based Services
truly rely on the Family guiding the
process the family has to buy into that
process um DCF intervention is them
coming to the house and checking in on
the house and checking in talking with
family members talking with a child but
the actual services that can be put into
the home um like High Fidelity
wraparound um Services it's really
meeting with that family hearing their
story telling them how can we help you
get to a better place what are the goals
we really want to see for your family
and then when that family determines
that they find others in the community
to help build around that family to be
their support system whether it be
natural supports or whether it be
professional supports and they're
building that at the family's Direction
often times it takes some time to get
there take some time to build that
Rapport but they are coming in with that
non-judgmental lens um it does feel more
judgmental for families when DCF is
coming in and say I have this allegation
against you let's talk about that but
when we're actually talking about the
services that can come in to assist
families they may have that information
but they're not showing up at a family's
door with a piece of paper that says you
did this to your child they're showing
up saying we're here to help how can we
work
together follow up thank you and are
families able to access those Services
um without DCF opening a case and paying
for some of them there are few services
that are accessible in the community
without the without DCF involvement um
We are continuing to try to move there
as a state but initially the way our
system was built out was for those
services to be offered through DCF and
so still to date DCF does have access to
additional Services especially high
intensity services so for children who
may really be struggling behaviorally um
those services that can come to the
house three or four times a week those
are primarily offered through dcyf at
this time and so there are still some
families that don't necessarily want to
become State involved but they know
their child's struggling and they will
go to DCF asking for help because they
know that the services in the community
cannot meet their level of need thank
you representative
Grossman thank you chairman Pearson um
thank you Office of the child advocate
for your always valued testimony
um how does this the amended version how
would it
affect some of those babies that that
have come through ERS or with broken
bones and gone home would this change
the trajectory for some cases we
strongly believe it would um because of
the addition of some language
here find those sections
um so page three on the bill as
introduced um if you look at C there it
talks about physical injury to a
child and that really expanded on what
we had prior um it the the important
role there is the or indeterminate means
if the parent or Guardian parent
guardians or custodians are the primary
or sole caregivers and have offered no
reasonable alternative explanations for
said injuries um unfortunately in the
many cases that we reviewed there was no
identified perpetrator and therefore
when the division filed petitions they
were not successful in abuse petitions
because they did not have that
identified perpetrator but what they did
know at that time is they did know that
the only caretakers for those children
were their biological parents and so
something happened in that household
between those two parents that harmed
the child but neither was willing to
come forward and say that because then
there's criminal implications for that
parent
but what that then did was limit dcf's
ability to intervene and assist that
family so by this addition here that is
now we don't need to have that
identified perpetrator to and um a a
perfect explanation as to what happened
we don't need to have that mapped out
situation of you know this is what they
said and this is law enforcement's um
rebuild of of the um incident they can
say we have not received enough
information and medical professionals
can say what was provided to us by
parents is not what could have caused
these injuries we do not have further
information but we can say that is not a
reasonable explanation so with medical
professionals being able to weigh in
that way and then expanding it to
include the indeterminate means that
would capture the majority of those
children the other addition is under
serious impair serious
impairment on page eight
in L um with the addition of any single
incident or occurrence of serious injury
or illness that did not exist before and
the importance of a single incident is
that with these babies it was a single
incident there was I believe one that
returned to the Ed for a full SK
skeletal that did have additional broken
bones at that point that were identified
but all the others it was a single
incident that led to it and so we do not
want to rely on Old statue that requires
multiple incidents to occur because at
that point the child may not make it to
that next medical visit and then the
final one is in the rebuttable
presumption of harm um on page
nine v um evidence of serious injury
broken bones or unexplained injuries to
any non-ambulatory child um this did
have an amendment to it because it had
broken bones in the plural um and we
wanted to ensure that one Broken Bone
Alone could be enough um to to show that
a child is In Harm's Way and so um that
is in the amendment they um provided
some parentheses around the S so it can
be broken bone or broken bones um but
those are all of the sections that do
address those particular
issues thank you
OCA thank you very
much
dcyf Susan larabe Jennifer Ross come
up you want to answer questions and
provide
information okay now you you're swapping
seats from last time okay good thank you
pay attention very
good and same thing um you are the ones
that were behind the presenter and are
there additional
explanations you might like to give
us if I could just start by saying again
good afternoon Susan laraby DCF general
counsel I think what gets very hard
sometimes when we look at bills and then
amendment of bills we're not looking at
the complete one the complete chapter
and here with
169c it is a very complex and robust and
wordy chapter there are 40 subsections
to this very important section uh
chapter and there should be 40
subsections but I think sometimes when
that happens we tend to only look at the
bill itself and not how it fits into the
already established act so for instance
burden of proof that has come up a few
times now that has been in the statute
not just in civil actions alone but in
this specific statute 169 C13 burden of
proof the petitioner has the burden of
proof proof to allege to uh I'm sorry to
prove the allegations to in support of
of the petition by a perance of the
evidence that's already in Statue this
bill does not change that this bill only
changes two very specific sections the
definitions but then the definitions
applied throughout the the act as well
as then the rebuttable presumptions of
harm which are not until the very near
the end of the ACT because the
rebuttable presumption of harm does not
change the definitions of abuse and
neglect it is under the evidentiary SE
section of the Bill of the ACT to help
us prove what is harm what is serious
impairment what is risk of serious
impairment and that's very difficult to
do especially with
psychological
abuse so I just want to put that into
context I think sometimes that's
overlooked nothing in this bill Bill
changes the due process rights of
parents and that's why there are 40
sections of this bill that goes through
every step of the process from the
initial call to Central intake to the
determination of whether or not that
should be screened in for an
investigation for an assessment while we
are assessing and investigating whether
or not that has been abused whether or
not there has been abuse or neglect
remember we are the the division for
children youth and families commonly
we're called division of and that little
preposition I think it's called a
preposition in grammar of and for are
very important distinctions we are for
youth we are for children we're for
families it's not adversarial sometimes
it may seem adversarial when when it has
to get to court and we talked a little
bit about those cases that have to go to
court that we have to prove the elements
of abuse and neglect by a preponderance
of the evidence we're not changing that
with this bill we're not changing the
due process rights of parents we're
trying again to enhance how we work with
families deputy director rth can talk
more about that if necessary but again
we're working so hard towards that
prevention step working with them with
voluntary Services providing the
services that they need to become the
parents that they want want to become so
I just want to sayate that again we're
here to answer any questions you may
have about this bill or any practices
policies procedures that we have at
DCF good afternoon Jen Ross deputy
director
DCF I I Echo um what attorney laraby has
to say um and we've talked about
services to family there are many ways
that families can access Services um and
it doesn't always have to be um a
petition of abuse and neglect or us
removing a child from their home to have
Services we have voluntary services that
we can um you know provide referrals for
for families to access within their
communities we do have our paid services
that we can provide to families when we
do become involved um but the the um
ability our ability to um to um support
families is only going to grow in this
measure um I was the child protection
field administrator that uh office of
child Advocates uh s uh Cassandra
Sanchez and um attorney um massio were
referring to when we started to talk
about the children who were um
experiencing significant injuries um but
yet were um not receiving the services
they needed nor the families to help
understand how those injuries may have
occurred and then how to you know
support the family so those didn't
happen again so we do work
collaboratively with each other to talk
about how we can service families and
children um and again our job is to you
know ultimately protect the kids um and
ensure that their safety um is protected
while in their family unit and working
with the family together so again happy
to answer any practice questions any um
additional questions you might
have is D of
cyf full strength or short
staff we um are always um hiring if
anyone wants to J um yeah we are um at
78 capacity 78% capacity in our
assessment um area of practice and we
are at about 90% of capacity at our
family service uh area of practice um so
is it fair to say that one of the
reasons why sometimes something doesn't
get the attention it deserves is your
staff's already working full Tilton
there's more cases potential cases than
there are staff workers yes we have been
fortunate over the past several years uh
the legislature has offered um the
ability for us to hire several new
positions particularly in our assessment
phase um which is the initial phase of
work with families where we're
investigating the allegations of abuse
and neglect and making determinations so
we have been able to um hire additional
staff in that area of practice which has
helped with the outcomes that families
are experiencing but also the turnover
for our staff we are seeing an increase
rise in case numbers because we are
offering more voluntary services to
families and working with families
outside of court but through an open
case with the division so we are seeing
um the case numbers um case loads rise
in that area so um we are looking at how
to um also support our family service
workers um yeah as well thank you yes
questions representative Mel thank you
Mr chairman for taking my question um
thank you what you're providing here I
think is very valuable uh we were
earlier hearing talk about psychological
harm um what Provisions in this bill or
what Provisions in the
DCF stable if you will allow for
clinical assessment of psychological
harm and what do you see for example as
the potential for uh diagnosis of
psychological harm and I'm going to also
include in that the the inherent risks
associated with a differential diagnosis
if this is going to be done without
clinical
assessment yeah so I can speak to the
practice side um our investigations are
done um with the family and it we also
rely on um information gathered from
other sources um and so we are talking
to as um the OCA um had represented we
are talking with schools we are talking
with medical professionals we are
talking with mental health professionals
and other individuals who might know the
family and be working with the family at
the same time so our our job is to
gather as much information as we can
about the child and the family and
situation to truly understand what might
be happening um we do have access to
evaluations um you know that we can
provide parents and children and youth
um both at the investigation phase as
well as at the case phase um and so
certainly understanding we do have a
variety of providers that we work with
that are informed of our practice our
system trauma in in trauma informed as
well um and so we do work with multitude
of of different agencies to help with
those um evaluations and assessments to
help us understand truly what might be
happening okay so if you have follow up
I'm sorry thank you Mr chairman for a
followup yeah so for a followup um if
any of these matters do end up in court
for some reason so in other words you're
saying that if I hear you correctly you
have the actual expertise on staff these
people will be able to um be able to
make those kinds of clinical assessments
we do not have them on staff we have
them as providers that we um contract
with or you certify um to work with us
um and we can provide families referrals
to them or we can use whatever Community
partner that the family might be
comfortable using as well um so it
doesn't necessarily need to be a
provider that we have certified um we
can access providers you know throughout
the the um community that the family
might live in um and so yes we do that
does become sort of evidentiary if you
will within our hearings and our
testimony um it becom Discovery so
everything we collect during the course
of our investigation or even our case is
discoverable and is provided um to all
parties in the matter um and then we do
rely on you know Witnesses fact
witnesses to come in and talk about that
we're social workers we know we are not
MediCal providers we know we are not
Mental Health Providers we can't make
those type of diagnoses so we do rely on
the experts um to help us form an
opinion okay thank you very
much representative love
thank you Mr chair thank you for coming
to testify and and uh giving us all this
information uh a little personal history
uh uh 20 years ago I was going through a
divorce uh my get to the question
quickly uh so it's going to get can I
have a minute
no not for a backstory no no other
questions thank you thank you for your
teson thank you everyone
and as announced previously next I will
go to um state
representative uh per custom and then
after that we will take other pink cards
and everyone will have four minutes
chair calls Rec uh representative Paige
ban
it's on I wasn't sure thank you
everybody for having me for for being
here and for hearing me uh my name is
let me get to my notes my name is
representative Paige Bosman and I
represent nashua's Ward 4 I first here
want to express my gratitude uh for the
folks responsible for this bill for
drafting it um having had a career in
Maternal Child Health and as a mother I
am in full support of strengthening our
ability to protect children I am here
today though to speak to con some
concerns that I have about some of the
language in the bill and um with the
current language I do oppose this this
bill um I've been a registered nurse for
over 15 years and I've spent that entire
time working with moms babies and
families in several capacities inpatient
outpatient Health Tech I've worked uh
significantly with moms suffering from
maternal substance use and their infants
both prenatally and postpartum I've
cared for those babies that you were
asking about representative coren um and
I've seen both sides of that in in my
own care um my main area of expertise is
actually maternal mental health and I am
certified in that through the only
certifying organization in the country
um there are several pieces of language
that concern here and I will say with
the amendment it's been a little hard
for me to know off the bat this morning
what's still in there and what isn't um
but given that there are several
different pieces of it it is something
that I don't think is solved easily with
a few word changes and one of the
reasons um that I have that concern is
that defining substance use in and of
itself in any way as neglect or abuse um
is not how we would define it it
clinically so we really need to separate
the difference between having a mental
health condition which substance use is
and actual harm that it does to the
child so there are others who will speak
to that in more depth but what is widely
accepted in the space of perinatal
exposure is that fear of a referral to
DCF significantly decreases engagement
in both recovery programs and prenatal
care and substance use is a clinical
condition that should be addressed with
protocols that are developed by clinical
experts it's really important for me to
call out right now that per the
CDC perinatal mental health is the
number one cause of pregnancy related
deaths right now when taking into
account suicide and overdose and so from
this perspective let me go to my next
page um what I like to emphasize is that
while well- intended we know that this
bill is very likely to decrease maternal
engagement in recovery programs as well
as prenatal care and thus the bill
increases the risk for increased
maternal deaths in New Hampshire the
reason is that be regardless of what we
know we we might have talked about well
what will happen after they're referred
to DCF and it might be great the problem
is that regardless of we what we know
folks who are most vulnerable who have
been targeted before and I think some of
us know we support dcyf and we know
there's rooms for improvement folks who
have been targeted are often from more
vulnerable groups including those with
substance use concerns and so those
folks have a higher fear of the system
regardless of what we know is going to
happen they have a fear and I want to
share just a quick little anecdote um
this is a personal experience it's an
anecdote but the scenario is completely
backed up with evidence as some other
folks will attest to um I do trainings I
train folks in the clinical field how to
deliver perinatal mental health
screeners so screeners that will help us
find folks that have perinatal or
maternal depression or anxiety um a few
weeks ago I was training somebody now
this person is a clinical person
she happens to be a single mom she said
to us I personally would not take this
or would answer
incorrectly because of fear that if I
fail it which you can't fail a screener
but her words over and over if I fail it
dcyf will take my kids this is a health
care provider in the space of helping
moms and babies and that is what we're
dealing with that perception is out
there and when word gets out that there
are higher um that they'll get more
attention for it or that there could be
more referrals we are going to see fewer
people accessing the care that they need
um in
summary um I do respectfully request
that we vote itl on this bill in the
hopes that we can bring in additional
clinical experts I think that on this
side we didn't have enough of the
maternal um substance use uh uh uh input
here and I I know there's a lot of us
who would really like to help craft some
of the wording so that would it be in
alignment with what we know to be best
clinical practice for moms and babies
thank you representative today yes is
the hearing yes and if you have
additional experts or whatevers they're
here who are not here oh yes uh they can
certainly speak with the prime sponsor
if the prime sponsor is willing
wonderful are you willing to take
questions absolutely
but I don't see any wow well either I
did a really bad job or I answered all
the
questions welcome to the House of
Representatives thank you very much
thank you everybody chair recognizes
Jima wer
Wilder so I get gim and I blow Wilder
really how am I
doing JMA I'm going to go with wilder
for the surname
and remember we're on our four minute
thingy
here good afternoon Representatives my
name is JMA Wilder and I'm from Campton
New Hampshire I oppose House Bill 553 my
concern with this bill is the vague and
ambiguous language that it would allow
for unconstitutional abuse of power I
came here today not only for the
protection of precious children but for
the generation to come adding in
language such as emotional mental
behavioral and psychological needs and
Welfare allows for children and parents
to come under attack without having a
standard for
measure there are times when my children
don't understand the importance of
lessons such as sharing serving reading
math history caring for others and
sometimes proper hygiene when a child
becomes frustrated with these things
it's job as parents to help them see the
importance of it I have worked with many
children over the years and have had
Untold complaints about doing things
that were hard for them but helped them
grow and learn necessary physical mental
and spiritual lessons over the last two
decades the emotional psychological and
me mental well-being of children has
rapidly been on the decline there has
been a rise in suicide and decline in
mental health since doctor School
counselors and other organizations have
put so much focus on it when are we
going to consider some of the adults
having conversations with children are
causing more harm than good exposing
children to explicit questions about
body image sex drugs and suicide when
they have never even considered it plant
seeds and causes harmful thoughts when I
brought one of my children to the
doctors they were given a survey and
many of the questions had to do with
body image after we left the doctors we
talked about the visit and sadly my CH
my child shared that they had never
thought about their body image until the
doctor asked the seed was planted and
grew I spent years trying to make
something that came from a survey
claiming to help
children I I'm sorry I spent years
trying to undo something that claimed
from a survey claiming to help children
this bill is too Broad and allows for
Family Court to circumvent due process
without proving guilt it will also
include many cost uh major costs and
resources in a system that is already
taxed I ask that you reconsider this and
think about what's really good for the
children thank you any questions for
Miss
Wilder seeing none thank you so much and
next time you come I owe you 1 minute
and 22 seconds
okay welcome thank you I tried to
shorten it for you you did a great
job chair recognizes uh Matthew Hassel
it's a double barrel first name and I
can't quite read the other half of it
but come on down and fill me
in thought this is for Representatives
right now you're gonna have to sit down
at the microphone so I can hear you I
thought this was for Representatives
right now I'm sorry I thought thought
this section was for representative they
have finished
okay all right so I'm in opposition of
and you got four minutes starting now
itl I'm going to get right to the legal
principle of the state action Doctrine
which
exactly I'm going to get right to the
legal principle of the state action
Doctrine which is exactly what this bill
is State action this state action
Doctrine is a legal principle that
limits the application of constitutional
rights to actions taken by the state or
its agents it protects the people from
action Tak by the government that
violate their constitutional right the
doctrine arise to all levels of
government including federal state and
local it prevents the government from
directly or indirectly depriving people
of their constitutional right it also
prevents the state from becoming
significantly involved in the actions of
private individuals making those actions
the same as state actions the doctrine
is used to determine whether a claim
based on the Constitution is valid the
first three words of the second sentence
of the 14th Amendment are no state shall
this sentence declares that the states
may not abridge the privileges and
immunities of the people of the United
States or deprive people of life liberty
or property without due process of law
nor deny to any of the people the equal
protections of the law as recently
decided in the Supreme Court of the
United States in Christopher l Wilson
versus Hawaii on December 9th of 2024
Americans need not engage in empty
formalities before they can evoke their
constitutional rights as Wilson versus
Hawaii states we people do not have to
engage in the empty formalities of the
state before we invoke our
constitutional rights by enacting this
bill as state standing law and procedure
the governing body and its agents will
have failed to give the state and
federal constitutions its due regards
when this happens the government reduces
such rights to a second class of
protection and guarantees these
constitutional rights are not a second
class of protections and guarantees
subject to an entirely different body of
rules than the other bills of Rights the
state or its agents and agencies do not
have the right to inflict wrongs upon
the Free People by denial the full
protections of the law such as due
process of law within the meaning of the
fifth and 14th Amendment equal
protection under the law within the
meaning of the 14th Amendment and the
sixth and seventh amendment protection
to a jur trial which is what this bill
presents because all state officials
including yourselves are by the
Constitution to be required to be bound
by oath or affirmation to support the
Constitution the 14th Amendment of the
Constitution has vested in the Congress
of the United States the power by proper
legislation to prevent any state from
depriving any of the people of the
United States of the enjoyment of life
liberty and property the Constitutions
can by law provide against all such
abuses and denials of Rights by the
state and by state actors or
combinations of per persons or
corporations such as those who enact
this bill and those tasked with
enforcement for conspiracy deprivation
of rights under the color of law this
bill as proposal will warrant a finding
of unconstitutional State action
triggering the state action Doctrine in
a federal court as of this day I am l
litigating in the first Court First
Circuit Court of Appeals on an ongoing
Tor action against three state actors
for violations to the Constitution and
statutes just like this that case is
Hassel versus kimar case number 24-44
I depending on how that case is decided
will be further taken action to the
United States Supreme Court which is
protected by the First Amendment to
redress for grievances this bill is
opening the state and its agent and its
agencies to further Tor claims and
unconstitutional State action if this
bill is enacted which if passed as
proposed will be added to my case in the
event the case goes to the United States
Supreme Court as mentioned above in
Wilson versus Hawaii we the people do
not have to engage in the empty
formalities of the state given the
unconstitutionality of this bill it is
already self- defeated if enacted as Pro
proposed 20 seconds to
go as article one of the New Hampshire
Constitution State all government of
Rights originates from the people is
founded in consent as one of the people
I do not consent to this I oppose this
bill as
proposed are you saying that an agency
of the state has no rights
whatever to remove a child from a home
to violate the constitutional rights of
the state and the Federal Constitution
no they do not you have to give due
process of law you have to give equal
protection on the law this bill right
here does goes off the judge's
discretion and the judge
denies over and over and over again the
right to a jury
trial okay thank you any other questions
there's plenty more if you want the
actual yes uh representative sidel thank
you Mr chairman thank you um I'm just
curious if you could send us a copy of
your testimony do I have like an email
or I can just hand you this and you can
if you don't need it that'd be great
thank you yes
ma'am any other questions
any other
questions thank you and the chair
recognizes Leah kushman from
where thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Leah kushman I live in the town of wear
I'm a former state representative and I
am on the board of rebuild New Hampshire
and uh part of an organization called
assembly of New Hampshire people called
New Hampshire Family
Justice um a lot of great points were
made in the last testimony um and your
question at the end sir um just to tie
it in and explain how this is
unconstitutional um a little bit
further SEC versus jesi it was a court
case where it was a civil action by the
state
by the federal agency the uh Securities
and Exchange Commission against a fellow
named JY for fraud and the court found
that if a suit is in the nature of an
action at common law then the matter
presumptively concerns private rights
and an adjudication by an article three
or a common law court is
mandatory in essence due process rights
must be honored when the action is
similar to an action that at the
founding would have been um
guaranteed that due
process Family
Court treats abuse and neglect like
civil cases when that makes it so that
we're being um we're not being tough on
crime we're being lenient on crime
because it takes hearing after hearing
to get anything done and in the meantime
the child stays with parents unless you
have the EXP parte which is sometimes
used but
um requires a lot more um threshold of
evidence so DCF is blaming the
court the courts blame DCF and others
but
um DCF screening and the process there
is a big part of the problem every other
crime you have a complaint and then it's
given by someone in a police report or
an affidavit then they have liability if
it's wrong um if they they knowingly
gave false information and then that
gives them jurisdiction to move into
investigatory phase or get a warrant for
surveillance or search so they can go in
and obtain the evidence needed to get a
child safe immediately whereas DCF
requir uh Ries with the child protection
act on voluntary cooperation in most
cases so it gives people time to hide a
child to move a child um and this only
started back in the 80s prior to that um
these these were treated as crimes with
the full investigatory power of law
enforcement and the protections of due
process in a criminal court which is
very specific um so the soft on crime
approach is letting kids fall through
the cracks because they don't meet the
screening threshold and DCF basically
can make arbitrary decisions to not
follow up or if they don't make contact
with a parent they don't um they don't
follow up we saw that happen with
Harmony Montgomery um so to say that
you're going to use this process before
you go to a criminal procedure it's
backwards
this if this bill cited simply that
abuse was defined as a CH a conviction
of 20 seconds of of one of the um
criminal statutes concerning abuse you
know endangerment of the welfare of a
child uh sexual assault um battery
domestic violence and required that
before proceeding that would be fine
because that would be how it it used to
be up until the mid 20th century there
was criminal and civil and then there
was Equity time's up any questions for
former representative kushman
yes
representative yeah thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here um
my question is are you saying that you
believe that within DCF parents are
giving way too
many chances to hurt their
child I'm saying that we're not
following a consistent process there
there's a lot of room for
um arbitrary decision makak and they are
not trained law enforcement and from
time Memorial the common law and
criminal procedure in the United States
since its Inception has provided
consistent um you know guardrails for
how Crim crimes are investigated and
pursued and because they are treated
differently and there's a lot of wiggle
room for um discretion that yes
sometimes it goes in the favor of
someone who's hiding abuse of a child
and sometimes it goes in the favor of
DCF agents who are a little too zealous
and have maybe their own um personal
biases and are investigating you know
more zealously or you know targeting
someone based on their own
perceptions follow up oh sorry oh thank
you okay anyone
else thank you for coming
chair
recognizes giz
Glenn we have all these fascinating
names that I'm
butchering they're wonderful
names you'll need to turn that what I've
just handed out is a um petition to
redress list the Constitutional things
that they were referring to saying that
dcyf is a um creature of the legislature
and operating under legislature and not
under constitutional rights and
therefore violating constitutional right
fundamental rights of parents um my name
is like I said my name is grelli I am a
parent my children are currently in DCF
um custody they were removed from me
because I was homeless I'm going to and
I just want to validate and verify I
just want to affirm that everything that
I testify to up here that I can I can
prove I have proof and evidence to back
up what I
say so um I'm just going to read the
expar that was filed that was the cause
of removal of my
children okay on September 15 2023 the
division received a call from Heather
Moran from which Manchester City welfare
stating Miss Glenn was not eligible for
services due to monies that were
unaccounted for and was placed on a
14-day suspension Miss Glenn was
refusing to leave Manchester City
welfare and was stating that she was
going to camp on the lawn outside of
City Welfare with her two children
supervisor Megan bellan spoke with Miss
Glenn who was unable to identify a place
for her and her children to stay due to
miss Glenn being disorderly at City
Welfare the Manchester Police Department
was contacted Manchester police was able
to arrange R shelter for Miss Glenn
through families in transition through
the weekends today September 18th 2023
Miss Glenn returned his Manchester City
Welfare but was informed that she was
still not eligible for shelter nor that
fit had any open beds for her and her
children Manchester Police Department
was contacted again in Manchester City
Welfare due to miss Glenn's escalating
behavior and Miss Glenn was arrested for
resisting arrest and disorderly conduct
cpsw Elizabeth Barney was able to speak
with Miss Glenn prior to her arrest and
Miss Glenn was again unable to identify
a place for her and her children to stay
thus leaving the children without
appropriate shelter for the evening
based on the foregoing there is
reasonable cause to believe that the
children are in circumstances or
surroundings that present an imminent
risk to his or her life that the necess
that necessitate immediate out of home
placement the children are without
proper parental care or control or other
care or control necessary for the
physical mental or emotional health and
their health is very likely to suffer
serious impairment based on forego there
is reasonable cause to believe that the
situation in the home is contrary to the
welfare of the above referenced children
given the circumstances expart relief is
the only relief available for the
division I heard a lot of people say up
here that their main thing is to keep
the children in the home and that's the
first thing that they do but with this
with this expert fails to say is that my
children were with my older son I have
two older children one's 24 and one's 29
and my children were with my oldest one
of my oldest children um
DCF to not not DCF my experience my I
had my parental rights terminated 16
years ago to my three middle children
because I didn't have suitable housing
so here I am again I don't have suitable
housing and you remove my children even
though that's doesn't that doesn't
constitute neglect although I was they
did the judge signed off on this just
because I didn't inform them of where I
would be staying with my children as if
that's any of their business DCF has
enough power and that they abuse right
now as it is for us to add on all this
extra language to this bill to give them
more power to you to abuse because as it
is right now they don't follow their
protocols and they don't follow this law
because this expart should have never
been filed number one 15 seconds number
two and I object to that four minutes
because the stakeholders that really
don't have anything at stake up here but
we heard quite a bit from them so I
would like my time as long as it takes
for me to
speak okay this petition for redress
where do you expect to send this who's
going to receive it and consider it turn
your mic back on this is for all of you
who are on this committee to address to
redress that the issues with DCF and
this bill is not going to help to do
that and you're saying that DCF has I'm
reading it now no authority to interfere
with the liberty interest of the people
correct they are part they are A
legislature creature that running under
legislative laws which are not
constitutional fundamental
constitutional New Hampshire which I
wrote the the articles on there that are
that are corresponding to the
Constitution to the fundamental rights
that we are being denied on a daily
basis okay I got it thank you um any
questions from the committee okay seeing
none thank you as I said I think it's
unfair that you have gave everybody who
doesn't have anything at stake here the
chair now recogniz you gave everybody
out here who doesn't have anything at
stake and my children are at stake and
you don't let more minutes that is
correct put you in those chair by the
way my next call is to
security the chair now
recognizes
feran turn on your mic uh I will submit
th this online but I have a few copies
you can actually sit down oh you're
going to go do that
okay good afternoon committee members
thanks for having me my name is Farah
Shen I'm a representative uh um
representative sorry I'm a resident of
Amur New Hampshire not a representative
yet but maybe I'll do that someday why
um so my my uh written testimon is much
longer than what I'll share here but I
wanted to make sure that you had you
know more of the details and some
resources and uh my qualifications for
why I can share what I can share um so I
strongly agree that changes are needed
to
169c uh I'm a registered nurse I'm a
master's prepared registered nurse I've
been in the field for 30 years caring uh
in the Maternal Child Health realm um
especially with families affected by
substance use disorder and Trauma
so I know we need changes but I oppose
the bill as written now and I believe
that changes as written in this bill
will contribute to the harm of Children
and Families in New
Hampshire mostly what I do right now is
I work with Maternal Child Health teams
and state quality improvement groups
across the country and specifically
representative Corin work with those
families who are dealing with the
complexities of substance use in utero
and then the consequences of that for
themselves their and their
infants um there's a model of care
called Eat Sleep console that New
Hampshire was actually the first state
in the nation to implement this model of
care in all of our at the time 16 birth
hospitals and I was a leader in that
initiative and that education there's
now been research done on the eat sleep
console model of care um funded by the
NIH by the N National Institute of
Health and um basically every state in
the nation is saying please come help us
come help our teams
um implement this model of care and it
specifically addresses you know your
concerns so I can speak to that at the
end if I have
time um the language in the bill that's
the most concerning to me that I want to
speak to is the presumption of harm as
related to substance use so I'm not
going to read it because it's there and
you can read that but this is really not
a trauma-informed section of the bill
it's not trauma-informed language it's
not a trauma-informed
approach um and it's not a
trauma-informed way to protect families
and
children so I'm going to say something
that might sound contrary to everything
you've believed in your entire life but
it is the truth when it comes to science
and
research substance use by a parent does
not equate to child
harm it
doesn't a parent who has a chronic
medical condition in any other way like
diabetes maternal
obesity um uh and even other risk
factors like poverty or homelessness as
we just heard doesn't equate to child
abuse and
neglect is it a risk factor you bet is
it one of the most important risk
factors that our society needs to deal
with you bet does it actually equate to
child abuse and
neglect
no so one example of this is the
American Academy of breastfeeding
medicine which is our gold standard on
who should be getting mother's milk how
to get Mother's Milk you know what
should we do for encouragement and
restrictions and all that that
organization says if a parent if a
mother is nursing her child and she's
struggling with substance use or she's
using substances this is not a reason to
not breastfeed
let me say that again if a parent is
using substances in their breastfeeding
the highest level of Oran in
organization in our society who looks at
breastfeeding and makes determinations
with all of the experts across the
country does not equate it to child
abuse and neglect they do not say you
can't
breastfeed they say how do we help you
mitigate the harm how do we help you get
support how do we assure that your child
's outcome is as best as it can be given
the situation of your health your
chronic disease and your family that
might mean a mother is continuing to use
THC and
breastfeeding this is what is actually
happening in healthcare because that's
the science behind the best practice 20
seconds so we need to really look at
this bill and make some changes we do
but we don't we absolutely have to make
sure that we're taking out the
stigmatization and the Discrimination
around substance use we would never say
presumption of harm based on poverty
lack of housing maternal diabetes we
would never say presumption of harm
based on Parental trauma because that's
one of the risk factors so we should not
exclude or or like specifically pull in
one group of people because a certain
moral code has existed in our
country how about fetal alcohol
syndrome got to put it back put it back
on
sorry uh yeah so that's a a complex
issue right like there are situations
when when children have long-term
consequences however it is proven that
not all substance use leads to long-term
developmental outcomes and and and harm
in fact um neonatal opioid withdrawal
symptom is often a temporary condition
not a long-term chronic disease that a
child experiences as a result of
maternal substance use it's temporary
and how do we deal with that is we make
sure the baby is with the mother and has
cuddling and has has breast milk and is
in a low stimulated environment and you
know lots of other ways to deal with the
temporary medic medical condition it's
not a long-term consequence in all cases
so in some some cases it is and that's
what we really need to be looking at is
what is the actual harm to the child
it's not the substance use itself
representative rice thank you Mr
chairman thank you for your testimony
and thanks for taking my question so I
have to ask you because I think
everybody here at this table has heard
the stories of children who have gotten
to their parents drugs and are dead
death is long term so how do you propose
then that we protect these children from
that without this language being in this
bill just like we do with any other
child who could be at risk for anything
right so I have family members who use
farm equipment and Machinery they need
to make sure that their children don't
get into that and get hurt if they're
not if they're not protecting their
children from the situation that they're
in in their home then that's unsafe but
that could be across the board that
could be for someone who's taking you
know prescription medication for their
mental health care we can't say oh you
have a mental health condition and
there's drugs in your home to take care
of you therefore we're going to you know
a presumption of harm and make sure that
your child you know is involved with DCF
we say what is the actual Behavior
that's putting the child at risk not the
condition or the disease or the things
we're using to help the person you know
be
well follow follow up thank you Mr
chairman
so I can't wrap my head around this
canot because um I have heard stories of
of children who who are dead because
they they got into their parents
fenel you're your mental health
medication comes with a childproof
lid okay Sentinel you're buying off the
street does not and I just really feel
that that that makes no sense no sense
to me because we're going to end up with
a lot more dead children and I I can't
be a part of that can I respond yes
you'll see in the written testimony I
don't have time to talk about excuse me
that um one of the problems is that
engagement as Paige discussed engagement
with the system when families are
struggling and so my belief and actually
what um evidence shows is that when
families actually can engage and they're
not afraid then it leads to better
outcomes for children less D and less
maternal mortality and morbidity so it's
actually I know that it's hard to wrap
your head around because this is
something that we have all been born
into in our culture that substance use
means bad person substance use means I'm
going to be unsafe and it actually
doesn't sometimes it does sometimes
having a farm is unsafe sometimes being
homeless is unsafe but not across the
board we can't just blanket it as one
group of people it's discriminatory and
it's actually not
accurate repres be great
but D
Simone thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um you said you were
a nurse correct yeah I am follow up
follow
up um and you talked a little bit about
uh the nursing mother who may be um
involved or addicted to drugs correct
yes followup
followup so um failure to
thrive is a very
important uh
um condition for an infant and can cause
lifelong effects and is that correct it
is thank you okay so in the case of a
mother who is a cocaine addict comes
into an emergency room the baby has
failure to thrive because the baby can't
suckle because in the milk is cocaine
would you say that would be a
detrimental effect of the drug addict
mother
first of all fail failure to thrive is a
very complex uh condition that is
usually
multifactorial um and so when there's a
situation where there's a parent using
substances and that's affecting their
overall ability to be able to care for
their child then does does an
intervention need to happen yes I'm not
saying that that shouldn't happen I'm
saying that blanket substance use as
presumption of harm should not be part
of our our our code you know our our
statute thank you for your testimony
you're welcome anybody
else yes representative George thank you
chairman um thank you for your
testimony um I just just in case like
you said about addiction and the drug or
alcohol like as a representative right
ask you for protection I would like you
to know how how really you can protect a
child I want to really know because I
didn't how can we protect a child in a
situation where parental parents are
using substances in an unsafe way is
that your question to me yeah
well it's um we need lots and lots of
ways to do that you know we need
resources for housing so that parents
aren't unhoused we need more funds for
mental healthare and substance use you
know what we need New Hampshire we need
a residential treatment center where
moms and babies can be cared for
together and not separated we need
foster homes that are willing to take in
mothers and infants together um we need
trauma informed educated Workforce
across social medical and you know
Educational Services and systems I mean
I could go on I could probably write a
book and maybe I will but um there's
lots of things that we need but to
stigmatize one group of people and and
call them out in this legislation um and
in the in the existing 169c that we
already have is wrong and it's not
safe any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you for listening chair
recognizes Randall
Coler Randall Coler
good afternoon representative um chair
and representatives um kind of against
this bill um there's been a lot of
fallacies um spoken here today
um title 42 um is a public health and
warfare it's a non-positive law title um
it seems like these agencies the
Executive Branch State agencies um
they're obviously not following due
process and if these statutes are
actually going into Circuit Court
um and we and before someone was talking
about uh preponderance of the evidence
and difference between criminal and
statues uh and civil sanctions and
whatever um so if we're talking about
civil
um the Fourth Amendment of the
Constitution says probable cause can't
come from civil disputes so
um judge Garner was in here and he said
that um Rules of Evidence don't apply
what they want to be as a gatekeeper for
Reliable information judge Gardner wrote
in my odor that Rules of Evidence do not
apply and um Rules of Evidence do not
apply to the orders I seek to vacate so
criminal statutes in Family Court
without evidence and he denied the
motion to vacate the protective order um
sir we're going to ask you to address
the bill it sounds like you're
addressing a law case I'm addressing the
unconstitutional actions of these
statutes in Circuit Court where evidence
doesn't apply which means it's not a
fair court and has does apply the Rules
of Evidence are different I've read that
book several times all right well you
may continue and I'm not penalizing you
for my speaking go
ahead what do you have that says Rules
of Evidence do apply because I have it
in writing from the from the executive
administrator Garder um that Rules of
Evidence do not
apply so let's time out and try and
figure this out because now we have a
contrast and any ambiguity in any law
always favors the defendant
so um I got a lot more to say but the
circuit courts uh administrative law
courts can't hear uh constitutional
claims that's why they take our kids
away um kidnapping page stalking uh
extortion you name it that's what they
do so I'm against this bill because
nothing in it is is going to change I
like the constitutionality of it but
it's an unconstitutional court so to
having constitutionally verbiage in the
statute doesn't make it
constitutional so I haven't seen my kid
in six hours and 12 years because of New
Hampshire Family Court Michael Gardner
so we do not mention names
sir well he's retired so we do not
mention
names so you're saying that Rules of
Evidence do apply and I have it in
writing that they don't so I'm not I did
not say that continue you did say that
if I did can I have a recording from the
record anybody no you may not yeah then
let me clarify the The Rules of Evidence
apply in the discretion of the
judge well no that that's illegal you
can't do that you don't have discretion
on the evidence either the evidence is
there and if it is there of a crime then
you get transferred to a superior court
for
constitutional uh okay you've got 30
seconds left to tell us why we shouldn't
vote on this
bill because it's
unconstitutional
okay any questions
this committee will eventually vote on
this bill based on this bill and any
questions of the
constitutionality is not our place to
decide I believe it has been decided it
perhaps will be red decided but that's
not what we're doing here today when we
exec we will exec on this bill if we
think it's a good bill or a bad Bill the
presumption is
this bill may be put forward others it
is their job to rule whether this is
constitutional or not that's not us
chair recognizes um Courtney tan from
Dartmouth
Health just wondering if you've had a
chance to read the amendment I have you
have review I I review yes review it
thank you
hi for the record Courtney Tanner I'm
the senior director of government
relations at Dartmouth Health you guys
have complicated and heavy topics in
this committee um and I'm coming with
coming to you today with more
complications so um want to thank you
all for your thoughtful consideration
Dartmouth health is home to um a number
of programs that I'm proud to be to
represent a couple of which are the
Northern New England perinat quality
improvement Network we also are home to
the um State's only child advocacy
Protection Program and we actually have
partner organizations across the state
one of which was mentioned here today we
have a partner program in at a hospital
in Manchester and it sounds like that
provider was maybe involved in the
drafting of this but for the record
darou Health was not involved in the
drafting of this um Bill we do have some
concerns as an institution with the bill
particularly around um I'm looking at
the amendment now on the first page
lines 27 um there is a reference to
being born uh alcohol or substance
exposed and so um have some concerns
around how that's implemented how that's
defined um that you've heard testimony
today about how there are um clinical
best practices around children who have
been exposed to substances in utero um
and uh we I don't want to repeat that
that test for the committee but just
want to underscore um some of the
testimony that you've heard from uh from
a nurse just two testifiers ago so we um
I want to underscore that we are deeply
committed to the safety of infants that
are born in the state to Children um but
do have some concerns about the
amendment as drafted we would be happy
to work with the committee on the
amendment um but but we do have some
concerns I also have written testimony
that I will send to the committee it's
in a PDF form and I will email it to you
um from one of our providers ERS I'm
happy to take questions I'm not a
practicing clinician not a clinician at
all um but happy to take questions if
and make myself available to the
committee this amendment has not been
formally introduced because we are not
in an exact session the chair made a
ruling that since this is what we will
probably consider we should consider it
now and not fight over stuff that
probably won't ever appear in an exec
session if the prime Spa answer wishes
at some point to uh consult with anybody
everybody or nobody that is your
prerogative so that if the amendment
when we have an exec session is exactly
this amendment that is your privilege if
it is changed that is um Your Privilege
as well and uh representative George
would you pass down the blank pink card
because people are now using Straight
pieces of no to me thank you ah because
people are using Straight pieces of
cardboard which is very creative I
think I know so if you that's what's
that oh that's somebody that's an old
card does anybody have a blank pink card
up their sleeve okay chair will take
this
one oh you do of course you
do well all right could you could you
fix this thank you
anyway we we oh keep those cards and
letters coming anyway it is up to
representative Greg as um the prime
sponsor you may bring in an amendment on
exec day in whatever form you wish in
cons consultation with any folks here
not here or wish they were here or not
as you choose so that's how working with
the committee will take place
okay any questions
oh after that I was hoping it'd be no
okay thank
you former representative Betty gay of
Salem come on
down and she says she wants to speak for
four minutes that's what I want
to okay uh I've passed out a blue a blue
sheet oh blue sheet okay you're not on
the clock just yet uh blue sheet blue
blue blue it has
references it has references on it
where this blue this color blue okay
good thank
you okay let's take the blue sheet out
with the dirty printer that I could not
clean let's look at the blue sheet
follow the blue sheet because repres
former representative Gaye four minutes
is about to start now okay the
co-sponsors and sponsors of this bill
read like The Who's Who of people who
are concerned for kids and I I feel like
one of them um I have a criticism of
this bill that I wish could be built
into it I don't want to trash the bill I
just want it fixed um Aces Aces were
mentioned adverse childhood experiences
those are critical the if somebody has
four of the 10 the chances are that will
lose 12 years of their life so we are
talking about really serious things um
I'm curious about what's the difference
between
psychological versus emotional abuse to
me they sound like the same it sounds
like kind of
Overkill um immediate intervention
removing children requires immediate
investigation to verify or clear
apparent
uh one of the reasons that family court
has such a bad rep reputation around
this world is for the errors that are
made they either don't remove children
or they remove children who shouldn't be
removed and speed is of the essence so
whatever if you're going to do an exp
parte because you think a child's in
danger you not only need to do the
remove the child quickly but you need to
investigate quickly because we are aware
of many people using it as ammunition
against a parent they're trying to get
even with so then they know that that
child's going to be removed probably to
them for an extended period of time
while this investigation slowly takes
part that is
cruel there has to be a review this is
my opinion this is what I want to see
put into the bill there must be a review
of the judicial court order by a review
board who are not part of the Court the
only review we have right now is the JCC
judicial conduct committee they are
staffed by attorneys and Court employees
it's no wonder that they almost never
find a
finding well the Review Board needs to
be created consistently of child
psychologists pediatricians
adult
psychologist people who are not part of
that of of that
investigation but they have the
expertise that can evaluate the family
one of the other bills that people are
asking for is that whenever a child is
going to be
evaluated or or be treated they' be
evaluated first to see if there really
is an issue there that the child need
needs counseling or the family needs
counseling let's start with
knowledge and the the last thing is the
very name description of the
bill triggering a rebuttable presumption
of harm in abuse and neglect rebuttable
presumption of harm is the
opposite it presumes that you are guilty
and you have to prove that you're
innocent so it's backwards to
start any questions for not only former
representative gay but alumna of this
committee am I correct well no I always
wanted to be on this you always wanted
to be and you wanted to be me on this
committee only then I didn't get elected
and you got put on this committee life
is
cruel I got that
anybody uh I've mentioned this before I
don't think I've mentioned it to you uh
we made some beginning progress in the
special committee on the Family Division
of Circuit Court basically we picked lwh
hanging fruit and I think we did some
good work um I asked the speaker if we
could come back and try a couple more
years because of the trust level we did
not come at them adversarially we came
at them collaboratively to gang up
together to fix problems and they worked
very well with us but now maybe with
that trust level we could go a little
little bit higher up the tree to some of
these other issues I asked the speaker
therefore would he reconstitute that
committee and he said no but what he
said was Mr chairman you can form a
subcommittee out of this committee and
continue the work so I probably will and
I'm suggesting that what you said if you
could put that in a memo to me about
where you see one of the problems now
Solutions are not obvious necessarily
uh some people were accusing judges of
knocking off work at 4 in the afternoon
what that meant was that was the last
case they heard you know my wife the
last person she sees is a doctor is at 4
in the afternoon she gets home at
quarter to 8 the problem is not the
judges in this case the problem is
there's not nearly enough of them so
things have to be put out because
there's a whole bunch of other people
needing to have a court case before we
can get around to you again we need more
judges and uh this may not be the time
to do it that is one aspect of this your
point about a
review panel on judicial orders that may
be something we would want to consider
but could you put it up in about five
paragraphs and send that to me because
I'm collecting possible topics for our
next round as we work with family court
thank you and may I make the suggestion
that crafting bills that affect the
court could also use their input so
rather than just counting on their
acquiescence and liking your ideas that
it actually gets put into writing into
bills instead of just practice you may
be excited to know that some of us are
doing just that uh perhaps we could do
that some more but certainly uh for some
of us who have uh relationships with
justices we've run things by them I'm
testifying on a bill tomorrow that has
spent a lot of time with the
administration of circuit court so that
it's uh something that could work but
thank you for the suggestion anyway
anybody else last call did I use up
every second because I wanted to say
what this is it was what I said you have
precisely 22 seconds to tell me what
this is okay this is several several
different sources for information
because people like to say oh the courts
favor women or the courts favor
men family court has a bad reputation
around the world especially in all the
English-speaking uh english- speaking
countries so they have they have good
ideas but this shows you that really
things need to get fixed and it's not
just slanted not just for women or Not
Just For Men Thank you and you owe me 14
seconds next time okay and I'll email
this to you so you CLI I appreciate that
and that goes to anybody else on the
committee if you if you've got some
thoughts about what are some things that
circuit court uh could be improved in
you know their their constant word to US
during this process is hey we want to
make things better right you heard that
so if you've got some topics again brief
you know the the lawyers call it brief
but they're not you be brief in both
senses of the word please okay anybody
else no so this we are on 553 this
adjourns the hearing on
553 and we'll exec it one of these weeks
thank you
all what's the
matter you did oh you know what people
were coloring on It come on up we're
back in again oh I'm sorry we thought
this was we thought this was left over
from last time thank you for jumping up
like
that you know oh my apologies I will be
so brief because I know I'm now
standing for a new future with us yes
thank you hi for the record msv need
children's Behavior Health policy
coordinator at new Futures we are a
nonpartisan nonprofit health care or
health advocacy organization dedicated
to supporting all Granite State Children
and Families um we are here in
opposition to the bill as written um
specifically I just want to call out a
provision that's been um cited already
um under the neglect statute or neglect
definition section e on the amendment
it's lines 27 through 29 we've already
touched on it we have the same concerns
that have brought been brought up that
this may have a chilling effect on on uh
pregnant parents seeking treatment um
both for substance use disorder and for
pren prenatal care and uh subsequently
perinatal care um we would suggest
removal of this provision um in which
case we would I think have no position
on the bill um and would look to maybe
additional uh improvements that could be
made but little tweaking yes yeah but uh
that is the main concern we have with
the bill happy to take
questions seeing none thank and thank
you for jumping up like that we lose we
have we are learning pink card passing
skills today aren't we well no you're
are no I don't mean you I mean others
okay thank you thanks
you haven't had your turn yet this
adjourns the hearing on 553 thank you
all e